the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
legacies are defined in Legends born at
the U.S Juniors and Senior championships
in St Louis with titles on the line
limits were tested and challenges met
despite immense pressure a draw was
enough for 13-year-old Alice Lee who
clinched her first title to become the
newest U.S junior girls Champion there's
a tie going into the final round but the
juniors are totally up in the air with
multiple players in contention for the
crown the senior championships have a
new Legend with melanchachian drawing
his game to become the 2023 U.S Senior
Champion the finish line is in sight who
will win it all day nine of Championship
chess coming up next
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome to the final round of the U.S
Juniors and seniors chess championships
we are here in the playing hall waiting
for the players to arrive but this time
the tensions are high and sex are even
higher let's go back to the studio and
start today
we have two Champions and are looking
for a third welcome to what might be our
final day of coverage of the junior
junior girls and Senior championships
from the St Louis chess club coverage
begins now
hi I'm a woman master catriona and I'm
here with Grandmaster Yasser Sarah Juan
wow okay that went fast we're in the
championship rounds the broadcasts are
almost over almost over but still last
round with a lot of crazy battles ahead
especially in the junior section no
question about it hello every hello
everyone and Welcome to our show if you
like Championship chess we came to the
right place as we have crowned two
Champions already will we Crown a third
Kate do the honors and tell us our
standings let's start with the girls
here we have Alice Lee who already clean
ER title 7.5 out of eight I mean
incredible performance fantastic and we
have a two-way tie for the second place
through Yang Yang and Zoe tank both with
Five Points a big fight per second and
in the junior standings in the junior
nothing is clear so far we have two-way
tie for the first place
with five five and half points but
closely behind them we have three
players Brandon Jacobson Andrew Hong and
Balaji dakopathy with Five Points it's
crowded at the top and tell us about our
Legends in the legend again we do have a
US senior Champion for this year it's
Malik said catching with six and a half
out of eight I mean securing the title
one round ahead absolutely fantastic
performance second place so far Alex
shabalov Five Points and third clear
vladimiracopian with four and a half
points Kate tell us about the format for
these three national championships the
format is three ten play around Robins
meaning each later Place everyone else
in their respective tournaments the time
control is classical chess 90 minutes
for first 40 moves followed by 30
minutes for rest of the game and there
is a 30 second increment for move one no
draw offers allowed whatsoever and we
have the traditional scoring system 1.4
win half a point for a draw and zero
points per loss okay remind me about the
playoffs yeah we do have potential
Playoff scenarios so if there is a
two-player style for first we have a
two-game rapid match with 10 minutes
plus 2 second increment if they are
still tight Armageddon is gonna decide a
champion and if there's more than two
players if three or more players tied
for first we have round robin a rapid
tournament 10 minutes plus two seconds
increment still tight Blitz match or
Blitz around Robin with three minutes
plus two second increment and it's still
tight Armageddon is gonna be decisive
and there's playoffs would we play
tomorrow at the same time as all of the
rounds have begun and we're very
fortunate to have in studio Christian
good to see you my friend for this
Championship round good to see you guys
and welcome back chess fans to
Championship Monday here at the St Louis
chess club we already crowned a couple
of Champions but it is time to
potentially Crown our final Champion as
well today and of course let's start by
giving the flowers to our deserving
Champions and we're going to start with
the senior section of course we see
Grand Master Malik said katian he is the
2023 U.S Senior champion and he is
twenty thousand dollars richer so that's
not bad at all but take a look at this
score line absolutely Majestic he
started off with two victories I have to
say in that second round very difficult
game that was anything could have
happened he was lost out of the opening
but he was resilient enough to get the
full point and that dictated the tone of
the rest of his event just an incredible
event the event of a lifetime for Malik
said and he was so happy yesterday I
have to say deservingly so and what
happened in the junior girls section
well it is this young lady feeder Master
Alice Lee she is the 2023 U.S junior
girls champion and she gets home six
thousand dollars Richard also she's
punching her ticket to the U.S Women's
Championship later this year as you can
see also I'm blemished score line no
losses and perhaps this is what you need
to do in these championships to go home
with that elusive title just simply
don't lose any games and win a lot of
them as well incredible performance by
this young lady but there is still one
championship in which everything is to
be played for and that is the junior
section as you can see ABI Manu Mishra
and arturgo are the co-leaders going
into the final round but closely
following behind is a pack of three very
hungry wolves that is Brandon Jacobson
Andrew Hong and Balaji dagupati and
let's take a look at the head to head as
we are entering this final championship
round this is a big one I'm having my
eyes on Brandon Jacobson versus Andrew
Hong these two players are very good
friends and I've seen her than yesterday
at dinner Dairy they were hanging out
with each other but I'm sure after that
they both went to their respective hotel
rooms and started preparation this is a
huge Clash that we will see coming up in
just a few minutes another big Clash is
of course this one Arthur Gua versus
gazarian Kirk has been slowing down in
the second half of the event so
potentially Arthur with the white pieces
we've seen how resilient he was
yesterday I have to say yesterday
yesterday it was a big test for Arthur
because he was worse out of the opening
and
um Liang was putting so much pressure on
him but fortunately for him he was he
managed to survive Arthur grew and I
have to say that must have given him a
lot of confidence going into this final
championship round and of course another
huge Clash that we have to talk about
and to my eyes this is the Marquee
matchup of the junior section in today's
round is this one Balaji dakupati Five
Points half a point behind the co-leader
ABI Manu Mishra and I have to say Balaji
has been in tremendous shape started up
very slowly the tournament half a point
out of two loss in the first round but
after that he was just his brilliant
self and right now he is on a hat-trick
potentially he's going to be able to win
his fourth straight consecutive game
today against the co-leader abhimanyu
only time will tell we have a lot of
exciting games ahead of ourselves and we
might Crown another champion today thank
you for that Marquis matchup and Kate
tell us about all of the pairings uh
start with the girls yeah so let's take
a look what is ahead we have Leo against
Atwell Yip playing wood that is going to
be a really cool matchup very
experienced players then Mo against tank
another important matchup for the medals
mangalan with Lee Alice already enjoying
her title but still definitely wants to
push forward and prasanna against Yan
and all of it and here is our champions
of her and drowned Alice leave the board
there her first national championship
yeah after four tries and tell us about
the junior appearance right so in
juniors everybody is really fighting for
that first or second place you against
vancopathy against Mishra that is the
key matchup against gazarian again we
have the co-leader playing a very
important game Steelman against Liang
and Jacobson against honk and for the
Legends uh what pairings can we expect
there here kaidanov playing dookie
loogie wolf against Ruth shabalov
against catching we have the former
Champion playing the current champion
akopian against gurevich and navikov
playing Benjamin and let's go to the
World Chess Hall of Fame and uh zoning
on the players as they're getting ready
to do battle this was going to be the
key matchup shivalov versus uh mirrors
but it was not to be as shubalov did not
win his penultimate round game it was
looking that way yeah it could be
forcing a showdown in the final round
right it just wasn't meant to be Malik
said got the title with round round to
spare and we had dinner last night and
he was asking us what should I play
today should we play should I play some
fun stuff maybe a dragon let's wait and
see if I'm having some ideas about what
he could potentially play in today's
round but he's definitely out to have
fun yeah I mean what a great story you
get a wild card for this tournament and
one around to spare you're already the
champion exactly
here we go Brandon Jacobson there's
Brandon another key player smile they're
very good friends very very good there
are buddies Andrew
I wouldn't even be surprised if they
were like roommates at times during this
type of big competitions
over the course of time
and we have a uh
guest about bellringer
Ted uh Middleton there he's the director
for the development of the chess
Educational Center here at St Louis
chess club and Scholastic Center yeah
[Music]
let's go
solid ring yeah it was very very solid
I met Ted at the casa chest in her look
at that Mishra didn't even write down
the move he's so ready to go and
Sicilian on the board so he is here of
course to fight very important game did
we expect I mean to be honest I did not
expect to see Mishra play so aggressive
work
because Balaji is
a player that definitely encourages this
type of positions he loves to play the
sillions he loves to play with the black
pieces as well he's a Syrian player
right he's a very aggressive type so
Mishra encouraging him to well follow on
this path that's expecting Snyder
yes I think Mishra is an idol player
enjoyed F6 let's see three A6 he's had
some problems right let's not forget
that game against Josiah stillerman
where he was completely lost and the
opening phase didn't go his way let's
see A6 maybe Knight C6 by the way we see
the stylistic matchups here and of
course I'm referring to the peace
placement if you see mishra's Knights
are facing forward whereas
uh F4 well the allergies are on the side
I'm telling you man he's he's an
aggressive player he wants four to fight
in every single game
these are so beautiful when we see
closely the night I mean
so well crafted exactly uh the move f2f4
was very very popular in the 60s and it
got usurp Bishop G5 by the 70s became
the go-to move uh but because it's been
so long since uh we've seen F2 F4 by the
90s people were playing F3 and Bishop E3
in the English attack right uh
what's the latest and greatest uh on
f2f4 well five is the main line E5 yes
yeah now Knight B3 was already played
which is in fact the second most played
move in the position of three in general
right F4 you want to drop the Knight
behind the pawn that you just moved
um but Knight to B3 that's an
interesting wrinkle that perhaps will
stop
I'll be monitoring his tracks at least
for a few minutes and give us the main
uh the the main pathway what what
usually happens after Knight B3 just the
typical development Bishop to E7 maybe
bishop to E2 it feels like white wants
to develop on the king side I don't
think we're going to see a long Castle
perhaps just a short Castle Bishop P2
and short castle and saying that with
that pawn already established on F4
your natural development with Bishop to
E6 is not going to come that easy
because whenever you go Bishop B6 maybe
I have ideas of playing the move F5
right you are pinpointing and perhaps
even with the King on G1 on that side if
I manage to get F5 in I don't think I
will shy away from expanding with G4 G5
and trying to get an attack on the king
side all right very good and Kate where
would you like to take us I would like
to go to generous girls and let's see
honestly what she's doing because
they're pushing fonts one step at a time
that Alice had played the Caro I thought
let's go and and again Alice uh so far
unblemished she would love to keep uh
the to take the title and to do it uh
without losing a single game uh d2d3
um with the inclusion of Knight F3 this
always struck me as a very strange
Choice by white because on the one hand
you're kind of encouraging a trade of
Queens in the loss of castling so you'd
almost think well why aren't you playing
Knight D2 to avoid this uh E7 E6 whoa
into into French that's a yeah a strange
move and C5 so it's like a French
defense so we can get to D4 and
and this is what you meant when you were
saying they were pushing uh one one
square at a time c2c3 I wonder if you
just trade yeah I think it's a direct
transposition right if you play C3
Knight C6 D4 you've just transposed into
the advanced French
if a funny transposition to be sure all
right and again in the girl section big
big fight for uh Second Place let's just
check in on the game of Iris and Zoe
this is not an open Sicilian but Bishop
B5 check Bishop D7 takes takes Queen E2
okay going there and finally Rue Yang
Yan and Gracie whoa they've played
really fast what happened here okay this
is one of those alappin variations right
within the early 95.
Knight D5 pardon me takes takes
uh guys let's move really quick to to
this one because this one is just about
when what yes shabalov wants to get out
of there Malik obviously awesome
wow okay any problems with that very
popular variation for making we would
call these Grand Master draws right
Bishop takes C6
uh
The Exchange variation of the rui might
as well repeat it like five times just
to make sure nobody's going to I mean
Alexa did claim draw yesterday
inaccurately
time second was accurate so right now we
are just making sure they have done it
12 times repetitions
Okay so
I had it wrong all all the way I said
that we're going to see some dragons
some crazy stuff going on no no nothing
yeah
our uh congratulations once again to
Malik said to to make it through without
a single loss that's that's very
impressive like you said winning formula
don't lose and win a lot of games well
in I believe in the Juniors the only
player that has that formula still
intact which now is Mishra yeah he
hasn't lost a single game he's been
making some draws he was cool sometimes
from losing positions right but he
always survives with like incredible
resilience yes yes that's true and
that's extremely important just to
refresh every and this was a variation
known for a hundred years the real Lopez
exchange variation Bishop G4 h2h3 I
don't know who was first to play the
move h7h5 but it's been repeated quite a
number of times ever since C2C you don't
mind if white takes that Bishop because
the file really opens and we see we see
exactly right really happy kind of
attacking that King quickly exactly
Knight takes E5 and this is the
repetition Bishop to D6 attacking the
Knight well I can take your queen which
is exactly what uh shabala did but this
is the draw just the King has to go into
the H file back and forth they went
until they had satisfied the three move
draw Rule and again our congratulations
to the new uh champion and first
Alexander shabala it's probably also
very good because he's securing exactly
second place I believe yeah some is it
secure trait no I thought I I don't
think it's I think one player of
Vladimir kopian with a win could
potentially tie him for second place
that's so tybreak he's sitting here in
tie break
and uh what do you have for us Christian
well let's look at this game guys uh
Balaji the Marquee matchup in uh the
junior section against abhimani because
I see some interesting things happening
in this one naito B3 was played Knight
to C6 and Bishop to D3 and the only game
that pops up right now is from one
bolaji dagupati with the white pieces oh
really against David Brodsky at one of
this U.S junior championships as well so
he's played this position before but
take a look at this bishop to E7 was the
way in which David responded and abimani
responded as well today and now we have
the first novelty in the position Castle
was played before castle castle I think
it was uh something along the lines of
Knight to D5 and then H6
Bellagio by the way got the pretty
decent advantage in uh that game so he
has very good memories very good
experience in this line but today he
decides to come with this intriguing
novelty F6 take a look at this for
example if you go D5 right I'm most
likely going to take take and now I have
ideas of Castle be very careful you have
to do something you have to release the
tension of the knights because if you go
Castle
take take F6 oops the game is almost
over you still have Bishop to C5 you're
not immediately resigning but this one
is looking really really bad of course
you cannot touch this one because
there's a discovery check I'm going to
pick up your queen so that's a big big
problem you have to be careful as black
and it does seem like this novelty has
stopped abhimanyu right now in his
tracks he's trying to understand hey
I've analyzed Castle because he played
it against David Brodsky what is this
new detail this new Wrinkle in the
position F5 what do I have to worry
about
intriguing another game I want to draw
our attention to is the game between
Gregory kaidanov and Maxim nalugi
because it's a classical for nights
Sicilian open Sicilian and in this
specific position I mean we have seen
multiple games of Knight take C6 D takes
C6 E4 E5 and then the theory keeps going
on for another
two dozen moves
another way of playing is Knight to B5
and you can go into espejnikov after uh
Bishop G5
and again the lines of theory are
remarkably complex and deep and then of
course you could do other standard stuff
that you normally see in the Sicilian
a2a3 non-standard I would say well sure
you're stopping Bishop P4 but you're
wasting a tempo
on a non-central move and that was
really surprising for me Bishop E7 was
Max it as his reply I would play the
move
d76 myself personally because I'm no
longer fearing a a Kara's attack whether
you play it with Knight takes E6 because
you've also already played them yeah and
that's not going to scare anybody that
was not what Max played Bishop E7 Knight
takes C6 on the board I'm anticipating
uh B take C6 and I wanted to turn my an
ass Christian what's the story with a2a3
by Gregory kaidana let's take a look at
this A3 has been played many many times
really in fact yes yes is the fourth
most played move over 400 wow games in
this position basically just stopping
the move Bishop to B4 right it's pretty
obvious you don't want to see this pin
being established on the A5 E1 diagonal
the only way and the best way to stop it
directly is to go A3 and you're
basically wanting to play a normal
Sicilian position shavening in type of
position with the pawn on A3 which very
often is in fact quite useful in this
type of structures now the big question
is going to arise later on are you going
to Castle on the king side or are you
going to Castle on the queen side much
more aggressive on the queen side after
this move Knight ac6 he's starting to
establish that answer and give us that
answer most likely we're going to see
the white king land on the king side we
expect B takes C6 maybe E5 in the
position Knight to D5 Knight to A4 Queen
to G4 is also move you committed so I'm
I waited for you with this move A3 you
committed the bishop on uh E7 and now I
can play this move Queen to G4 with a
Tempo compare it to what we have
let me see if I can draw back yes to
this game Arthur Go versus Kirk azarian
very very uh intriguing overlaps in this
one take a look
we had the same position but Knight to
E4 not Queen to G4 why not Queen to G4
because the bishop is still on f8 you
have not committed that Bishop to E7 yet
so we see some interesting
transpositions between these two games
take a look at what's happening in the
game big one Arthur Go versus gazaria
Arturo is one of the co-leaders exactly
and they're playing a very wild
aggressive opening very theoretical as
well
and guess who's much better prepared at
least in my estimation so far it is
Arthur because right now Kirk started
thinking Queen to B8 is by far the main
line Queen to C7 in fact I don't even
have it in the database and right now
the computer is saying that black is in
trouble remember what happened a couple
of days ago it was Arthur Zoo versus
kirgo's area out of the opening Kirk was
completely busted bastard the engine was
saying plus four right right that's a
decisive Advantage sure you still have
to do the conversion part but that's a
decisive Advantage right what we're
seeing right now is once again Arthur
pretty much out playing uh out foxing
his opponent out of the opening Queen to
C7 Queen to B3 is a very good move in
the position that's going to attack the
Knight on B4 and it's very important
generally we put the queen on B8 why do
we do that because very often whenever
you land the queen on B3 or you attack
my knight on B4 with something I have
the defensive idea of playing the move
Bishop to A6
which is very often a very useful move
for a black because I'm exchanging light
score Bishop my light score Bishop on B7
is a pawn
I want to exchange that right right from
B8 I'm also defending the Knight on B4
from C7 I don't do that and that's going
to be a detail that's going to make all
the difference in the next few moves
well also for me I don't like the move
Queen C7 at all because I'm always
thinking that whenever the Knight lands
on D6 check I can't tolerate the Knight
I'm gonna have to take it but then it
gets recaptured with the tempo right so
Queen B8 looks like such a superior move
the move Queen C7 played in the game I'm
anticipating F2 F4 just defending upon
on E5 and by the way you know I'm
getting ready to chase the Knight but
the move Queen B3 also looks very
attractive because I'm gaining in pretty
nasty Tempo I would say queen B3 is much
more difficult to be played just a bit
unnatural a bit computer-ish you have
big computers even though Queen to B3
followed by maybe Queen to G3 exactly
well after you get rid of the night you
go F4 for you don't want to see Knight
C2 check right right yeah but once you
get in you know these moves F or just
defending the pawn on E5 asking black
what you'd like to do just to let you
know actually I don't have to go A3
which is well first of all if you start
with the queen B3 first you can do queen
B3 A5 and now Queen G3 and you're giving
me the Rook okay Knight C2 is completely
losing apparently for black really Indy
one yes followed by Knight D6 96 check
once again
going to be undefended right takes takes
not losing this is over over in fact
over yeah just over because any queen
move in the Ruckus trap right you cannot
loan castle with a queen on the eighth
rack yikes
yeah
and again this game is so critical to
our standings as Arthur comes in tied
for first gate
very important if he manages to win his
second years either first place or
playoff playoff and he's certainly
looking really good here with this
misstep queen C7 by Kirk and again I
mean it's pretty clear that black would
love to play Queen takes E5 and pick up
the Knight the problem is is after Queen
B3 I get your knight you get my knight
that is for sure that I get your Bishop
as well and that makes all the
difference in the world in Queen C7
really is boy the more I'm looking at it
and especially because of that line that
was just shown To Us by by a Christian
that the when the queen slides over to
G3 how incredibly powerful that is uh
the queen looks terrible on C7 this move
threatening check and threatening to
take on G7 that's a killer yeah white is
enjoying a lot of space right The Palms
are really Advanced 19 enter on a great
square right yeah it's it's it's gone uh
terribly wrong for Kirk the Christian we
have a
a premature guest in the studio not like
you've helped so many students along the
way here in the United States win
championships get World youth European
World youth medals and finally you got
your own Championship right medal tell
us about your initial feelings thank you
yeah yesterday I got so many like
attacks so many like messages like thank
you Christian yes I did like have helped
many kids to win like what you for
Cadets like pan amps I mean many many
tournaments but myself I had never won
any national championship
I mean I don't know uh maybe my I'm not
sure what to say and I'm very happy I'm
very relieved and first time ever I I
want uh I won national championship and
very big one
I mean it's kind of breakthrough toward
me for myself uh I was hoping for it I
worked hard I changed everything in my
life and listened like what six months
or so diet and physical conditions uh
chess trainings I
I took many uh I mean not many but few
very strong students that also helped me
a lot uh were working with International
Masters working with grand Masters you
know that Christian it also makes you
being like stronger because you must
follow like you know like your Trends
new ideas everything and um that made me
because I used to be one of my issues
was let's say I was kind of predicted I
would say but then working with a
national team working with ladies with
girls and working with my top students I
start to expand my my openings and
everything I start to get uh
just feeling more comfortable to play
different type of positions so
and it helps me a lot
one of the things that I found very
difficult whenever I'm coming from a
long layover is just getting the dust
off the shoulders did you feel any of
that or you've been playing Sanchez
previous to this tournament as well
right no I mean yeah you're correct
because uh one of my issues because I
don't really Play constantly because I
have no time for that I'm full-time
chess coach and um and that's perhaps
the reason why my my rating was kind of
uh
I would say very inconsistent and
dropping because in most of the cases I
was let's say facing those really young
talented kids like 2200 range and
I couldn't beat them like every
tournament I play like plus one plus two
whatever it is plus three sometimes but
still losing my rating and uh but um I
always knew uh I'm not let's say 2400
player I always knew I mean I I can't
just I can play chess much better than
this rating
um
so what for this tournament uh as I said
I mean mostly I realized when I started
my games from previous U.S seniors I
realized uh most of my games when I
played against strong players I'm kind
of giving away the points after third
hours like between like four hours close
to the time pressure
so what I start to understand like
what's the reason why I'm doing this I
came to a conclusion it's actually most
of my physical condition
because at some point I'm stopping like
absorbing the board properly you know
like my brain gets off
so the first thing what I have done like
I said I paid attention to my physicals
I dropped some weight and I started to
working on myself and and I think it's
mostly paid off yeah and you also
mentioned actually at the beginning of
the tournament that he took a completely
different approach to the training for
this one you actually took a vacation
with your family spent some quality time
with them I want to give you the
opportunity to give thanks to your
support system yeah I mean my wife is my
manager for sure yeah I mean she
insisted to go to the vacation and for
my birthday and we again when we plan a
vacation actually we didn't realize it's
going to be like a U.S junior I was
hoping for it because one of my kids
playing here royakumachi gave me the
dates I thought okay maybe I'm going to
get this invitation so I managed my
vacation for those dates just in case
just in case no seriously it's true so I
made this vacation and then I was I took
a laptop with me with my files and
everything and she's sitting on no
laptop no files you me kids that's it so
the only chance whenever they were going
to sleep I was I was still going through
some some lines kind of you know a
little bit working for myself there but
mostly you're right this was completely
like shadow of my brain
not a single lesson they said what to do
the first time ever in my life like for
six seven days no single lesson online
none zero so just the kids family my
wife and uh occasion my laptop
for myself they said that this is the
first big uh I made adjustment uh second
big adjustment
um somehow I found a right uh formula
here it worked for me
I used to be doing gym every day or at
least every other day this time I
stopped doing that yeah I only like was
working outside a little bit
uh like a half an hour or 40 minutes
yeah yeah and then I was trying to pay
attention mostly to sleep what I did
like before the game every time like I
have an hour 40 minutes late now
it actually helps me a lot yeah
because when I was forcing myself to
close all those curtains you know my
entire names just to sleep in in the
darkness uh and that kind of it's kind
of made myself like uh calm loosen up a
little bit Yeah calm yourself so waking
up around like uh 12 15 12 10 quick
shower and to the game so
and it works perfectly so every day it
was perfect for me so look out well you
could also the manager for probably
pointing you out in the right direction
congratulations
U.S Senior Champion guys any question
for our champion Kate yeah
congratulations really fantastic
accomplishment I'm curious you said that
you had like no expectations for this
tournament because in the last one you
did not do very well but can you
pinpoint the moment or the game in this
tournament when you realize like hey
maybe I can actually win this
well yeah
um initially when I came here I was just
trying to have some fun and play game by
game interesting game I still be doing
that but I mean my beliefs
came after round two uh firstly in the
first round I played bloodman Copa and
very strong grandmas The Legend and I
always had uh kind of you know difficult
result against him and so when somehow I
predicted the whole thing the opening
and
I was kind of happy because the I knew
everything uh the position and I kind of
had the feelings like Vladimir perhaps
did not expect this line from me
and when I got like a and I also feel
somehow I feel I I have seen more in a
game than Vladimir because he clearly
missed the idea of Queen H3 he played
him his idea of 96. so this made me like
believe I can do this first time the
second time when I uh when I survive
against nobikov yeah I've been a survive
against novikov that game was in my
opinion crucial it actually started to
make me think okay maybe it's your
tournament maybe you can do it maybe you
can do it and maybe you can you know
push your dices and then um I guess I'll
tell you like uh I would say the final
final sort of beliefs came after the
game against mitigure which when by
usually having very tough fight against
Dmitry and somehow with black pieces I
got easy win
so for me it was uh clearly this kind of
sign that is it's my tournament you know
absolutely yeah look at that beautiful
score line Malik once again
congratulations thank you so much thank
you absolutely and uh turning our
attention now it's a fight for the
second place uh going on just looking at
the game of Vladimir kobian uh versus uh
Dimitri gurvich and this line I I don't
know if they refer to it as a king's
Indian or a grunfeld but again this line
was very very popular in the K versus K
matches uh Kasparov versus karpov and
these fights between getting the one
player wants to play 95 the other player
wants to play 94 and they had uh some
great discussions from uh this uh theory
of this line
um did the case and they're still early
days in this one but it's all about the
Junior Years Christian and the game of
Mishra tell us update that's the big one
and um I have some very intriguing
updates for you take a look at this what
happened in the last couple of moves
after a very long think F5
almost 20 move uh 20 minutes think he
played the move Mishra there is a knight
to B4 immediately responded by A3 Knight
takes D3 Queen takes D3 once again he's
in the tank
and this one is critical because if you
don't make the best move in the position
you're much worse so if you play a
natural move Castle right why not Bishop
G5 and the engine is saying that you are
close to busted I'm going to go long
castle and then you're going to have
huge problems with the pawn on D6 right
Bishop takes F6 is going to come Queen
takes D6 you're going to be a pawn down
and in fact you don't get a lot of
compensation for it so this is big big
very problematic and he found the best
move he played the move H6 this is the
best move but let's zoom in on the game
because I'm actually quite curious yes
G4 this was the move that I was
anticipating and he played it a la Tempo
he still knows exactly what he's doing
right now upon sacrifice you're not
gonna take that you're not going to take
on G4 because after Rook to G1 I think
you're in big big trouble this one I
have to say I mean Balaji is looking
really good he's had his he has his
opening preparation on the board right
now in a very sharp position and the
pressure is definitely on Mishra and he
showed that in general especially out
after the opening he's had a lot of
problems he very often got into worse
positions whenever he is surprised he
has been predictable in this event and
his opponents have been taking advantage
of it this must be an amazing feeling
for Balaji right because he needs to win
with white sure and he has
he has his preparation he has to kind of
really attacking chances so I think he
is getting what he wants in this last
round Mishra is not comfortable you can
see it right now and why is this such an
important game well there you have it
it's not just about the fight per second
for Balaji he's thinking I can win yes
he wants to win he he wants to win the
championship right uh victory over and
please Arthur don't you
have a playoff you said G4 crucial move
and don't take the pawn and I say well
why not let's just take a look Knight
takes G4 uh give me the pawn now you're
gonna play Rook G1 and I'm going to give
you a check
in the middle of the board and you can't
go to D1 that's that's a mind Square
you're likely to go to E2 and I'll go
back with my knight I I don't know if I
should play H5 or H3 but let's say I
just go back with my knight for a moment
and you take the pawn on G7 so
effectively uh we both have ruined one
another's King side and the more I'm
looking at this the more I want to play
H5 I apologize I want you to play H3 if
you're willing
this way my my vision is to be worried
about the bishop a little bit right and
now we we mutually mauled one another's
um uh King side Queen C7 whose King is
worse I mean both kings are bad but
right but I like that whitening plays
simply like Bishop E3 and then the rook
and
I mean I don't even know if I want to
slide over to G1 probably I want to look
on D1 anyway Rook David won and that
kind of thing okay and I'm castling and
again I'm just like sitting here asking
um
whose King is more vulnerable uh you
allow me to take that pawn I I will take
it well okay I
yeah I I was hoping that my my well wait
a minute
six and there's a there's a there's a
big night coming to D5 yes there is
wow okay that that was my question was
uh at the end of the day if I do take
the pawn on G4 uh if you if the kings
were
whose King was more vulnerable another
sorry another one Rook G1 H5 H3 Knight
back Rook takes yeah right let me put my
queen on a on a less useful Square Queen
E7 Bishop E3 something okay sorry I'm
thinking about like Knight A4
is probably more Bishop to D7 yeah
Knight B6 okay you did get your knight
too I really don't think he's gonna take
that pawn on G4 I don't either it is
mind you know poisonous
like he just played the move G4 you just
simply try to tame the position as fast
as possible maybe bishop D7 something
along those lines
taking is a really big bold decision if
it doesn't yeah but I think white is
black is probably fine here so I have to
be a little more careful well yes it's
totally fine if you know what you're
doing but I I was going through some
variations and they're absolutely wild
okay please uh take it away so basically
one of the variations is like this which
page four can get two and now you can go
into the lions then with a move Knight
to F2 and after Queen to F3 follow it up
with G6 and now we get this huge crazy
imbalance after Bishop to E3 Knight
takes E4 and Bishop takes F5 a lot of
Pawns on this side and a lot of points
for white on this side and an extra
piece King to D2 and this supposedly is
very close to equality but you have no
idea right as black that this is uh
equal right of course look at the
position you try to assess it good luck
assessing it under pressure from afar
you're not going to go into distance
that's why whenever I see Knight F6 as
the only practical retreat in this
position maybe after check or maybe
before the check let's say check just to
drive the king to H2 and now Rook takes
G7 if I don't see anything clear I see
this bishop a bit astray on H4 I don't
see a clear way of hiding my king I
don't like this straight because I know
that my opponent is ready for it I know
that he's analyzed this with very strong
engines which Balaji certainly has
proved up to this point so I'm not
simply going to go into that it's not
the practical decision I don't think
he's going to do it
okay fair enough uh turn our attention
to Brandon Jacobson and Andrew hung
because we have a very different
position than we're used to okay uh this
is all very very standard and after
castles if branding goes Knight to D2
followed by E2 E4 King's Indian attack a
favorite of Bobby Fisher's uh played a
thousand times c2c4 C7 C5 and now if you
want you could go E3 Queen E2 B3 Bishop
B2 and you know a thousand games
this move is definitely in my estimation
off the Beaten Track looks a little
strange I mean you you move a piece
that's already developed you're not even
doing it with a gain of tempo or
anything like that so I I would have
thought Andrew would be
less trade knife let me let me play the
move Knight D7 Andrew chose Queen C7
instead and provoke for F4 and usually
the combination of C4 and F4 is not it
is not a pair of moves that you see very
often and well I would be very surprised
if we're in theoretical territory here I
remember when I was younger my coach
would always tell me pick one you can
pick both both C4 and F4 uh Chris and
then again huge game for the standings
in the tournament very important because
Brandon Jacobson and Andrew Hong are
tight for third place so far but if one
of them manages to Island there are
chances that they may be playing a
playoff for the championship absolutely
and Christian tell us about the
combination of C4 and F4 yeah this is no
Theory
no it's not you're not supposed to play
like this because mentioned don't play
on both sides but look Brandon has been
signaling that he's trying to get out of
theory as early as move too right Knight
F3 G3 you play the ready when you just
want to get your opponent out of the
book and this is exactly what he got he
got a position in which both of these
players are
going to play by themselves there's no
engines there's no preparation there's
nothing it's just me versus you and this
is what Brandon wanted and this is what
he got sure the engine eval is saying
that black may be a slightly uh slightly
favor favored in this position but I
wouldn't say it's that clear and to my
eyes this one is just simply going to be
a game
I'm wondering by the way so if let's say
blago's 97 now right do we take and then
play E4 that's right yeah so we take the
Knight Bishop takes yeah Bishop takes
and we push an R Pawn E4 right right so
something like takes or takes I'm not
yeah it takes this guy why don't I do
that
six probably E5 or queen C2 E5 Queen E2
Knight C3 Knight C3
yeah we have this wig D4 square but
luckily we have a dark Square Bishop
that can guard it I think well the thing
is the Knight is
very far away from that D4 Square the
Black Knight Knight on F6 right so
it seems like this favors white just for
the simple fact that at that point you
can in fact change the structure with E5
but okay I see Yasser is already trying
to get well something else well if you
didn't like that that's that's the point
if you're planning to play E4 right and
then I agree with you wholeheartedly
that if you get your Pawn to E5 you know
you're kind of enjoying a little bit
something something after F4 maybe uh D4
so that in case you play E4 I'm not
saying that you have to or anything like
this you get a different structure
altogether
maybe I'm not in time to even and how do
we feel about this structure
black should be okay can I sacrifice wow
that pawn
can I go really crazy and go Knight C3
okay
let's give you that part with Knight B5
that's actually a very good question
maybe I think yes yeah let's do it I'll
put the Knight on B5 extra Tempo extra
Tempo now I have Bishop before yeah
there's no more Queen D4 check
that's nice and after Queen H5 we always
have if we want kind of a repetition
first we Bishop F3 button Knight C7 and
Knight B5 yes right yeah maybe I have
these Knight D5 ideas I mean there's
something to calculate right
yeah with
F4 the C4 F4 remember I was playing in
the world team and I Was preparing for
chakra midarov and Ben feinco would come
and you know coach me for a couple of
hours and then we'd go and have lunch
together and Shaq would was in those
days was very very uh often times
playing the grundfell defense
so I played D4 and we prepared the whole
morning for the grunfeld defense
both C5 and F5 and I sat there and I
thought about and said you know this
isn't the group it's I didn't even know
what this was was it the benoni was it a
a a a Dutch and uh this game of Andrew
hunt uh Andrew this is Brandon and
Andrew where you've got F4 and oops yeah
you've got F4 and C4 on the board I
don't even know how what to call this
it's not a bird yeah I don't know
opening uh and it's not in English
that's for sure we'll keep an eye on
this one where would you like to take
his cave uh maybe let's look around in
the junior section what is happening on
each board okay so uh we'll pick up the
action in Josiah versus uh Jason's
Stearman versus liang's game uh this
looks like a what
okay uh Queens Gambit
but with B6 and A6 I tell you the
opening circus these days I just don't
know what's going on uh in the openings
castles 97 Rook D1 Queen E7
and
if he said that this was a French
defense a Rubenstein French I believe
you I just don't know what this position
is I think black is
okay-ish uh but I like White's position
I'm not comfy right because anytime you
play like C5 I may actually push D5
which is usually very comfortable
position for what okay if I take are you
planning to take with a knight or a
taking with the I thought taking you in
a night okay so I have to give up my two
Bishops right if you take with a rook I
do have G5 although that's not the end
of the world I mean you may want to
investigate the potential the sacrifice
right
I mean that's a little bit weird to be
sure so maybe I should start with G5
here
just to make sure that we get the
position that I want not necessarily
what you want to start by capturing on
E6 Maybe
intriguing position uh I'm not sure how
I want to recapture
and uh by the way for those of you who
would like to join our conversation to
stump our panel of experts as a way yeah
people to join the conversation
absolutely you can always ask us
questions we have social media for that
the YouTube Facebook Instagram twitch
Twitter everything just tag the St Louis
chess club use the hashtag U.S Juniors
chess u.sinners chess or St Louis chess
club and we are happy to answer all
those questions and we have one so let's
see we have from chess sherper on
Twitter yeah sir what are your greatest
memories playing in the Juniors
Championship oh boy Dad too many we
don't have a enough uh enough air time
to tell you the stories one of my
absolute favorites was that the first
junior Championship I ever played in at
the time
there was probably about 12 Grand
Masters in the United States in total
wow so it was very very prestigious
title it was a very hard title to earn
and I was playing in this junior
championships with eight players it was
around Robin
and out of that group of players six
became Grand Masters wow
Championship two became International
Masters Ken Regan was one of them and
the winner of the tournament Mark deason
was the other International Master Mark
deason after he won the U.S junior
Championship went on to play in the
world junior Championship and he won the
world junior Championship and now they
give the Grand Master title if you
become the world junior Champion you
become automatically a grand master it's
not a yeah it's not a norm it's the
title so there was Mark Neeson who
didn't become a Grandmaster he became
the world but it was like
boy oh boy Nick defer me and Michael
Road John fedorowitz
Ron Henley all of these myself we all
became Grand Masters and it was like how
do you how does that happen how does one
class of players you know and again
there was only like 12 Grand Masters in
the United States at the time
it was an amazing amazing amazing year
and another one that I really really
liked I went to play in Another U.S
junior Championship in Denver Denver
Colorado and a guy John Jackson he wore
this big 10 gallon cowboy hat you know
and he took me out and he was the
organizer he was telling me all of this
stuff and I said well you know jacket
thank you so much for organizing the U.S
junior Championship he goes yeah
absolutely uh I I organized Fisher
versus uh Ben Larson as well
oh wait what yeah he said you're sitting
in the exact seat that uh Bobby Fischer
sat in in the same Steakhouse I said
what
it was like the guy who was organizing
the US junior Championship organized
Fisher versus bet Larson I was like tell
me more stories tell me more stories and
oh yeah no the junior championships all
right they're really really special and
they and you have memories they stay
with you your entire life and I think
that for many of us we became lifelong
friends as well and he also won two of
the U.S generals yeah I I in 1978 I I
went
to the world junior Championship in
Gratz in Austria and I remember I was
playing in front of my U.S flag and I
was up against the Soviets you know
Archer usopath and uh
yeah they crushed me but I got back in
1979 the World Junior Championships and
skiing in Norway and that was really
really a lot of fun so these World these
these Junior Championships I've got to
tell you uh they can really help Define
a career yeah and this reminds me you
are two times generic Champions right
four-time U.S Champion right Champion
but they are not yet a US senior a
champion not yet so that is a tournament
we need you tonight I'm telling you Joe
Benjamin won all the national
championships that you could possibly
win I kid you not I he Joel Benjamin he
won like the elementary he won the
junior National Junior National High
School Championship Junior Champions you
know regular Champions senior
championships he's won every National
Championship you can you can't compete
with that you can you can just start
getting into the U.S seniors tell us
about this uh thank you for the question
and tell us about this junior
Championship Christian just like a great
politician just evade the question all
day going to some completely different
girl let's go look at my hand good one
good one yes sir all right take a look
at this G4 he found for a very long time
to D7 Mishra that is this is the big
game the Marquee match of Balaji versus
ABI Manu he did not take on G4 I did not
expect him to take on G4 uh for obvious
reasons Bishop to D7 by the way the
engines top uh recommendation and this
one and right now I'm starting to think
first of all we don't see a move from
bolaji so definitely perhaps this has
been a surprise I was looking through
some variations and take a look at this
move Rook to G1 Bishop to B5 okay
isn't this just a pawn sacrifice can I
just simply take take
it is but it seems like after Queen to
D7 this end game you have to defend uh
the polony for we don't move Knight to
D2 this end game after move G5 very
important move to cement the pawn
structure on this side as is and right
now I have ideas of H5 breaking loose on
the queen side on the king side excuse
me and then invading with the Rook this
is going to create some serious problems
for a wide spawn structure also with the
Knight on D2 tasked with a difference of
the Pawn on e4 you don't have a clear
way of finishing your development right
so I have a lot of breaks I have D5 as
black I have H5 enough compensation for
the pawn so this one Bishop to D7 with a
clear idea perhaps Bishop to a B5
perhaps just a simple Bishop to C6 this
is what we have right now there's one
way in which white almost forces black
to accept the pawn sacrifice
and that is to just play the move Bishop
to D2 and continue the development
Bishop to C6 let's say and long Castle
now finally you're ready to take on a G4
and you're not worried about any Rook 2
G1 D or H because of Knight to F2 and
that's problematic right that's pretty
much game over you're losing an exchange
and you no longer have an attack
so what you have to do after Knight to
G4 is just simply drop back Knight F6
Rook to G1 and play a pawn down but it's
obvious that you have a lot of
compensation you have to defend with
King to f8 cannot castle of course
because of the typical pattern Bishop
takes H6 this is uh pretty much game
over so right you have to go king of
Faith you're going to be
um staying with the king in the center
for the time being you're not going to
get any sort of attacking opportunities
as black so definitely white has a lot
of compensation at the same time it's a
game with three results at this point
you have burned some bridges as white
gave up the pawn and right now you will
have to go all in for the attack on the
G file and we'll see whether it
succeeded but Balaji right now as we can
see this move Bishop to D7 has thrown
him out of his preparation
yeah for the first time he is actually
thinking in the game what you make good
movie good move very good move by
abhimani and the other key matchup of
the junior championships between Arthur
and Carrick I I'd love uh Arthur's
position he did play that move Queen B3
we liked it a lot it did provoke A7 A5
and the immediate Knight D6 we spoke for
a moment there about this uh crafty
little move Queen into G3 Knight D6 uh
to my eyes this is just a very very
powerful move uh by author takes takes
Queen to C8 and then I'm sitting here
thinking to myself you know what
I really like my dark squares I don't
even mind giving up my dark my light
Square Bishop so I'm really attracted to
this idea of playing Bishop to C4 and
I'm thinking this bishop on Ace
um
on B7 is really a big Pawn Yeah I'm
thinking that you would play the move
Bishop A6 right then I was going to go
Queen C3 gift me the pawn
now I'm hoping you're going to go
castles well hoping is strong but yeah
if you castle and then I was going to go
V3 and here's what I wanted you to do I
wanted you to take so that the Knight
ends up you cannot get even back to the
D5 right you can't get back to D5 and
then on a good day I've got these dark
squares and I just thought that this was
a huge Advantage a positional now uh
Christian also pointed out that well
you're not even losing a rook here
you're just actually just winning the
game on the spot if you go after the
rook and you allow Queen takes G7 and
Bishop H6 Christian pointed out that
this was going to be an easy win for
white so I think Arthur is coming out of
this opening this current position
in tremendous shape like really really
good can we do like Bishop D2 just to
develop that Bishop right and then go
something like h4h5 just yeah no I mean
that attack you you you've got space you
you can attack on the king side and even
in this case uh you can go Pond hunting
on the queen side as well it feels like
uh an a2a3 just uh he he Arthur wants to
Define where where the pieces are going
a2a3 no choice you're gonna have to by
the way correct I immediately played
Knight D5 well he had no choice right
he's playing like he still knows what
he's doing
it's surprising well Arthur knows what
he's doing Arthur is saying look uh I've
got this huge threat please uh be my
guest Castle right into a formidable
attack we've seen this pattern quite
quite a lot recently right right yeah I
think Alice Lee yesterday
she was going to go King F1 she's going
he's going king of Faith right now and
he's going to go kill yeah there's no
way he plays anything else and then
well okay Bishop C well but like At
first I wasn't sure I want to play A3 to
force the Knight to go away where the
Knight goes anywhere right but now I
understand he wanted the queen to be
free to go to G3 truly uh because I
think he felt that Knight C2 he needed
to chase the night away as Christian
pointed out maybe he didn't uh by the
way uh King f8 on the board uh rather
quickly everything else G7 G6 you don't
even want to contemplate you just
ruining all the dark squares so King f8
on the board Arthur is looking very good
by the way uh let's just go now that
we're here with the junior Players let's
just go around this is the Brandon game
and guess what he did play uh D5 D4 and
Brandon still he said anyway you can
take if you would like uh you're welcome
to do it E3 takes E4 and that takes care
of the Juniors and let's just go around
the tournament Hall girls with the
junior girls uh Kelsey and Rose what do
we got here wow
uh just a second Queen's Gambit decline
fair enough with the Armenian variation
with Bishop E7 but G6 okay so Rose is
thinking I want to go Bishop F5 and I
need the bishop to be defended there
exactly so Kelsey said please put your
Bishop on FM
uh no I'm not gonna go Bishop F5 in that
case once you've played F3
and F5 now that feels like rose is
trying to close down the position but
that might be actually helpful for white
I actually like Kelsey's position here I
think it's easier for white to play with
the space yeah it looks like black will
still have to figure out the development
of the queen side for sure absolutely uh
if you had told me at when the pairings
were known at the opening ceremony that
Carissa and Rochelle were going to be
competing against each other in the very
last round I would have said wow careful
that might be uh that'd be a big game
for first place yeah they're really
experience a very slow strong players I
mean in this tournament Alice Lee she
just she just won very very convincingly
but still this game is super interesting
because Carissa even Rochelle who are
very experienced player a very strong
karissaib is an international Master
Rochelle is a woman Grand Master so very
strong players and we have a Rouser
Richter Rouser which somehow feels like
a French defense you know they kind of
transposed and I don't know if we're in
a theoretical ground or or not but the
last move Quincy seven ideas of B4
Bishop A4 gift meet the pawn and Target
Singapore on E5 as well as E5 so uh
Carissa's being asked some questions but
wait a minute this also Queen takes G7
as well so after I probably want black
ones to capture with Queen on E5 right
to capture phone and defend the Rook
Queen takes E5 defends the rook and
maybe something of this nature
or F6 you say okay and again I don't
know if we're on theoretical uh Waters
here something will keep an eye on in
the fight for a second Zoe is
on the black side of a game with Iris
and this was this uh
anti-uh open Sicilian I want to say uh I
always think that black is doing well
whenever you have a French defense
without the light squared Bishop the
bishop 1 C8 log has a lot of troubles
brings a lot of troubles for blank but
when it's out when it's gone it's great
yeah there's no Bishop on D3 menacing
attacks against H7
usually that's fine uh where
yeah
oh Gracie sorry Rue Yang and Gracie okay
they played this alapin and blitzing oh
yeah they were they were going really
fast and furious there for a moment and
I think we've caught up on the play
wow they are playing quickly
an evenish ending
I remember winning a very similar
position at the Olympiad in the last
round with black pieces because you
target the pawn on E5 and sometimes it
may be difficult for for why to defend
it especially when you can't play a four
the night on F3 uh is in the way okay
something to keep in mind and finally
our tournament winner Alice Lee uh she's
been playing this very strange uh I want
to say it was a French defense but it
was a Caro Khan turned French defense
is something very bizarre uh by sriya
there she plays Bishop G3 Knight F5 and
then moved the bishop again yeah it
changes her mind she doesn't want to
give up that Bishop okay
a little bit of a logic glitch there
just a second and catching up with the
players and
feels like
black might be better yeah that one on
G4 looks a little bit misplaced I would
like to take it back yeah exactly G2 G4
G3 might be my my my best move here is
Alice looks pretty good shrey I might be
happy about like Knight D2 Knight E4
transfer but
but I can also try sometimes to open the
f file and again the bishop is unguarded
on F4 right
yeah I'm not a big fan of exactly uh
What uh Sharia has done but okay she
might be able to cover her weaknesses
quickly whether it be Knight D2 to E4
Knight D2 to F3 I thought h7h5 by Alice
will keep this game in mind and we're
gonna send it back to Christian as he's
been puzzling over our Marquee matchup
in the junior sector absolutely and uh
G5 is also a very big move in this
position potential Big Move candidate in
this position G5 take a look at the
variations after this first of all black
has a couple of ways they can deal with
this uh move right here H takes G5 which
to my eyes is the main one at the same
time it has its drawbacks as we will see
in just a second or Knight to H5 this
also makes a lot of sense the idea being
that after you take on H6 not taking
back on H6 that's going to leave you
with a weakness on H6 and Knight is a
bit off off play I Can Go Bishop to E3
get the king to D2 if you give me a
check and despite the fact that sure my
check my king is going to be stuck in
the center for the time being you don't
actually have enough resources take
advantage of that so take a look at this
after night wage 5 take on H6 you can
also play the move G6 lift the pawn on
H6 open up the light Square bishop and
this is the key in this position you
have to make use of the fact that
there's no opponent for the bishop on D7
because well we exchanged that a while
back so this is currently the position
after move Bishop to D7 G5 is definitely
one of the candidates move Bishop to D2
as well Rook to G1 also to defend but
definitely Balaji uh in this critical
situation right now he's definitely
pondering these very aggressive break
with G5 which is going through the
gauntlet and abhimani will have to
respond let's take a look no peaceful H3
okay
okay very peaceful nothing peaceful
about this opening by the way engines
are screaming right now they're saying
H3 ABI Manu is winning
after Bishop to C6
are you kidding me D5 yeah D5 is coming
right how do you stop the Five Guys
yeah I'm not oh this is really bad I'm
not a fan of H this is really bad really
slow no H3 was bad bad bad by Balaji
yeah I mean I've seen these lines where
you go Rook H2 and Rook D2 to stop D5
but it's mistimed oh my goodness yeah
the first move out of his preparation
and he just did not understand the
position correctly I mean the move X3 is
a little bit suspicious right because
when you play G4 you usually want to
follow with G5 or quickly long castle if
you have if you play G4 and then you
have to support the pawn
Bishop to C6 right now if abimani finds
that it's not the only move by the way
but Bishop to C6 is just the most
natural move I mean look you played
Bishop D7 last month exactly your plan
is very obvious exactly you want to go
Bishop C6 followed by D5 right and by
the what is Balaji thinking about
because I have no idea once you play
Bishop C6 first of all there's no way to
stop D5 I guess he wants to go Knight D5
really
okay that that's the only thing that
makes sense to my eyes
wow and uh invite I mean it's it's funny
how uh the the players don't seem
to be affected by having to move their
King right whereas I'm always uh very
very cognizant of these checks that's
why I was thinking of Knight takes G4 in
Bishop H4 check this just looks like a
very good position for black and the
thing is you don't even need that but I
don't even need to do this what if after
King F1 is
live and queen B6 is it feels like white
has just kind of misplaced oh he he
certainly displayed this one but you
don't even have to do this you can go
into CA the very simple route to C8 Rook
to see age I've been look I've been
looking at that B5 star for a while yes
and if you go C4 what is the most
natural move exactly oops sorry B5 B5
exactly
yeah this plays to the requirements of
the position right look you have the two
Bishops you're much closer to finishing
your development than white is you have
to open up the position and you have to
do it fast
idea Rook H2 Bishop
to see H3 Bishop C6 Rook H2 D5 just
mistimed right oh my goodness if I
capture point it takes
just mistimed I have to call a spay the
Spade this is just nerves right now this
last move H3 was just simply nerves Jack
is on board
no this is uh well this is just a very
good Sicilian for black where he's got
the two Bishops and he's got in d65 and
we always know in a sicilian where you
know this backward Pawn if you can ever
get
you can dissolve the weakness of the
backward Pawn with the move D5 and
your goal yeah that black is very happy
in Switzerland if they can manage to
play D5 no matter what type of Sicilian
it is exactly exactly uh game uh
oh but
we have a very special guest over to you
Christian uh thanks yes Rex first of all
welcome to the show I will ask you about
the games and these tournaments in just
a second but I first want to touch on
the anniversary that the club just
celebrated 15 years of the Saint Louis
chess club tell us about your experience
with chess
oh you don't want to know that it's just
horrible stories
yeah but 15 years is remarkable it's
really a testimony to the tremendous
staff we have and people like you and
and all of our commentators including
the great Yasser
he's in the room next to us yeah he's
listening that's why don't praise him
too much I'm watching I'm watching Rex I
have to say something nice you know
I I spent an hour preparing that remark
but it's just a tremendous testimony to
the staff that we've had over the years
they've done such a great job and I
don't even know what I'm doing here
these people are so Good by themselves
uh but it was great it was great to see
several hundred kids there from all over
the city coming in what a wonderful
celebration for everybody absolutely and
we can see that on the screen you we
even had ice cream
we had a lot of fun doc chess ice cream
and that's one of the things that the
Saint Louis chess club focuses taking
young kids from a young age taking them
all the way to the U.S championships
right and uh this tournament is
definitely aimed at that as well we've
grown and nurtured some of the best
talent in the country how proud are you
oh see Alice Lee here only 13 years of
age it's just amazing how far is she
going to go and and how quickly nobody
knows but right now it's uh it looks
pretty good pretty great yeah yeah and
we had Malik set he mentioned that he
received that invitation like a week
before Oh yes we were talking about that
last night and he comes in thinking well
you know might not be that great it was
terrible last year and look at him the
wind's going away you know absolutely
also no losses whatsoever is this what
you have to do in this Championship oh
boy I'll tell you it's tough to win you
know it's hard to win a single game let
alone what these people do to win an
event that's pretty impressive for all
of them Rex I have to ask you we need to
put some pressure on Yasser we need to
get him to play the U.S seniors
championship
I think he's too old
thank you Rex thank you thank you that's
what
I mean
thank you he's saying thank you you're
being nice to him right now guys any
questions
Big Time many questions first of all
thank you so much Rex for what you've
been doing which has I love being in St
Louis as a player playing the US
Championship as a coach doing chess
camps commentator journalist everything
is fantastic I really love being in St
Louis is the chess Capital but my
question is you know you've done so many
things in Saint Louis again U.S
Championship you know sing feel Gap you
have Casper over here Magnus Carlos and
you have the top women in the Karens cup
just what is the plan for the next 15
years what how do you want to Trump that
trumpet I didn't know that he was going
to be involved
well you know we still haven't had a
world championship here we need a world
championship with a St Louis Contender
okay at least with an American Contender
but that's settle for St Louis Contender
those are big plans yes sir well first
of all Rex just to correct you you are
on the appeals Committee of the 1886
World Championship here in St Louis as
you I remember I don't remember it well
so St Louis has already hosted a world
championship if you want to host another
one that's fine but I wanted to say to
you that thank you very much I had a
really really nice time last week we had
gone to the muni for the musical chess
you brought Chess the musical to St
Louis tell us about that how did that
happen
well you know they just approached us
and they said would you like to bring
Chess the musical here and I thought
about that should I Say Yes Should I Say
No I said well I'll say yes so that's
how it happened that's how I know it was
a wonderful thing and and we've been
talking about it and uh well what can
you say about that Performance Group at
the muni they are just out of this world
wasn't that magnificent it was fantastic
her all the time yep wow and you guys
got to meet them right yeah we went
backstage and met the performers and
there was a lot of children in the
musical as well they all got chess sets
uh from the chess club they were all
super happy with their swag so Rex once
again thank you for all your support and
everything that you and Jeannie have
done for chess it's it's been terrific
in the next 15 years you're way too kind
no not at all and by the way I'm a
little upset with you because we played
ducky chess and I'm telling you you were
a ringer you you made me play much
better than I I was a formidable
challenge what the hell I spent three
days preparing for it that was what I'm
thinking
I'm proud of your ex because that chess
is the greatest variant I'm telling you
Rex thank you thank you very much sir
thank you absolutely gotcha thank you
thank you wow uh no that that that whole
15th anniversary we couldn't believe it
by the way it was just it was so fast as
far as 15 was concerned and I remember
we were here it was a a Boy Scouts of
America was having the human chess set
but the astronauts had come because we
were playing against the space station
it was Earth versus the space station as
well so I mean when you think about how
many crazy and wonderful things have
happened here since the club's opening
it's been it's been how many kids adults
learn to play chess in the past 15 years
right that must be an incredible number
and we have news uh Christian between
that big blunder that Balaji just did
and he's following it up by the way take
a look at this we expected this after
Bishop to C6 Knight to D5 it's the only
thing that makes any sense right right I
believe that you're going to stop me
from playing D5 well sure you might do
that but you're not going to stop me
from going Bishop to B5 putting a lot of
pressure on the queen
first of all by the way let's take a
look at this bishop to B2 Bishop to B5
how do you protect both C2 and E4
right there's no Square in the position
that you're going to put that Queen in
is going to defend both of uh those
pawns so Bishop to B5 is a big threat
I'm looking at the position and maybe
you can go A4 C4 C4 by the way is met by
B5 we've already established that and
this is really really bad once the
position opens up so you go A4 but now I
can just simply take take and now I go
Castle
again how do you continue I go E4 next I
put a lot of pressure on the C file it's
all about the quality of the pieces
right now the Knight on B3 not doing
anything Nikon F6 is tremendous the
bishopon E7 right now a bit passive but
I'm going to go E4 I'm going to drop
back the Knight and then I'm going to
activate this Bishop from F6 or H4 or G5
I have tremendous quality infused in my
pieces you don't as white also my king
is safe your king is not this one the
assessment is looking really really Grim
for Balaji
couple that information with what's
happening in the artwork versus corgis
area one right take a look at this we
thought that Arthur was enjoying his
position nice attack
take a look at the last few moves Bishop
C4 Bishop Basics Bishop takes D5
big decision right now I was expecting
the movie yeah maybe me too but the
problem is after B3 you start seeing the
move A4 right and it's not that
comfortable right because you Castle I
have to take on B3 I have take back with
the queen you cannot take with the
bishop because you lose the exchange
it's not that easy Rook B8 is coming
with the tempo maybe later on in the
position it's not looking good so he
took on D5 C takes D5
Queen to C3 this is what we have but
I'm looking at the position I'm
comparing it with a few moves ago I see
this move F6 followed by King to F7 my
king feels very safe right now on f8 I'm
going to go E5 D4 if you allow me to
where is your king going right maybe
alongside Castle but then you're going
to have some problems on the queen side
as well you cannot Castle on the king
side yet maybe F4 King F2 you're going
to Castle like that
I'm seeing this imbalance in the
position and it definitely favors black
Kirk gazario and I am also looking at
the time Kirk without one hour and 14
minutes only 50 minutes for our tour
definitely pointed to the fact that he's
not comfortable with what's happening in
the position right now absolutely I just
uh add another thought to the game of
Mishra for just a moment after the move
Rook C8 with this threat of Bishop B5
and we were thinking well if I play A4
I'm a pond Grabber you know me I'm going
to look at takes takes Queen C7 and I'm
gonna say yeah go ahead play Rook C2 and
look at I mean I just feel as black I've
got complete command of the C file I'm
better on the king side as well as the
center
black ones everything is changing Queens
as well right I'm just getting uh so
Mish was looking really good as we're
gonna go on uh
uh break with the hold on we've got one
Brandon Jacobson Andrew honk they're
playing the variation that we looked at
uh about a half hour ago they're just
catching up with us Kate uh Knight b87 I
think we were looking at a pawn
sacrifice you will recall we were
looking at Knight C3 night uh takes E5
Queen B8 and we were saying well we have
at least a repetition if we like uh we
if we like it which is uh the Knight C7
night back this is where we got to and
the players are catching up with us just
before we take a break I want to take a
quick look at Alice Lee game sure
because we were looking at night BD to
there but I feel like Shreya was more
precise
so if we updated okay sorry let me just
do that yeah and she played Queenie too
now if we play Knight D2 as we expected
to just jump on e4 sure maybe black has
G5 ah you have to move back now I can
trade that Bishop
is this one free though is it yeah I
mean uh Alice might have to do a little
defensive work in uh this case but I
hear what you're saying that you you
like the move Queen E2 so you don't lose
the peshka you uh keep it nicely
protected and you prep right D2 all
right well we're going to take our first
break and before we do that we always
like to check in with our friends at Q
Boutique and I tell you uh at the risk
of repeating myself here it comes are
you ready for this I am the 2023 U.S
Senior Junior and junior girls
championships polos they're limited
edition and they are perfect for NHS
enthusiasts crafted from 100 polyester
the polo features the tournament logo on
the breast and the St Louis chess club
logo on the right shoulder show your
bride for the game and style and comfort
available at qbboutique St louis.com in
fact though all your shop chess shopping
needs at a q Boutique and support the
club the World Chess Hall of Fame we'll
see you on the other side of the break
foreign
[Music]
I'd say don't give up keep playing and
also just play for fun not exactly to
win or anything just enjoy the
experience of playing every game and
hopefully winning
[Music]
enjoy the game because I think that if
you enjoy the game then you will like
genuinely be able to improve naturally
and your hard work you will put in the
hard work
um and just like to appreciate like
chess it's a really amazing game there's
so many possibilities like each game is
different basically and
um yeah so just like enjoy the game and
your improvement should become should
come naturally from there I think to get
better you just need to love the love
chess as a whole I feel like it's really
difficult
um to like get better if you have a lot
of trouble like trying to be
self-motivated or work by yourself so
I'd say don't give up and keep going
probably just learn to develop your
pieces and Castle I still have trouble
with that sometimes so like just stick
to the basic principles
honestly it's just to like enjoy this
game like two and to like not to like
worry about like what what others like
you know like just like play play your
best definitely tactics some even like
above like reading chess books or
studying openings and all that just
mostly tactics recognizing positions and
then just like playing in tournaments um
playing wherever you can that's really
what I did honestly I would say try to
like play chess on your own terms
um I know I struggled a lot with that
um just like don't
um focus on just trying to like impress
everyone else play it because you love
the game and actually enjoy it we'll do
plenty of tactics oh and the main thing
is that you have to play a lot try to
play in as many tournaments as possible
and also play online games which
I would say you know if it's like their
first time playing Juniors I know it's
like a really almost like a stressful
experience to have your games be on like
um almost National stage and I remember
the first time I played here in St Louis
and junior girls I did not do so hot I
actually did really badly
um so I just said like kind of take it
easy enjoy the time you have here
um yeah enjoy the games that you play
you don't really know if you're gonna if
you like something until you try it so
you know chess really started to like
become really big during covid and you
know if you start playing an in-person
tournaments that's when you start to
really figure out if you really like
playing chess so my advice is go plan
some in-person tournaments especially
since we're in St Louis this is the
perfect opportunity to come and play
[Music]
thank you
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
hello I'm women's current Master William
takorjonova I will be doing social media
for the U.S Juniors and seniors chess
championships follow us in our social
media and get more exciting behind the
scenes action
foreign
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomes chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
hello I'm women's Grandmaster begin
Tucker jonova I'm doing social media for
the U.S Juniors and seniors
championships here in San Luis follow us
for more exciting behind the scenes
content
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varusha nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 200 50 000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write Jess thanks to Club co-founder
Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield anyone can
learn how to understand chess notation
in no time we chess as a valuable
educational tool learn more about our
Scholastic programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our live
coverage of the national championships
here are our result results one result
in the senior Championship travel of
Drew with kachin which is a good result
for catching who already secured his
championship title and shabab who is
trying to finish your second looking at
the game of the coping garbage but in
the junior championships all eyes on
these two games is Arthur go and Mishra
are tied for first coming in to this
one thanks for the U.S junior
Championship so we have two players
so far up tight for the first place with
five and a half points but closely
followed by three players Brandon
Jacobson Andrew Hong and Balaji dakupate
with five points and Brandon and Andrew
playing each other uh they're looking
both of those players looking to win and
to try to get in to a playoff and in the
girls standings after eight rounds of
play we have a champion already Alice
Lee with a fantastic performance she
already secured her championship title
six and a half points of eight and then
we have a two-way tag for the second
place so still a lot of fight today with
ruian Yen and Zoe tang with five points
and
let's just jump into uh the girls
Championship because I mean it's it's
the Alice Lee show she's just doing
tremendously well and everything is
going her way when we left it we left it
here and you were kind of complimentary
of shriya's move Queen E2 but I like
this move H5 and things really went
wrong for Sharia right here as well you
trade Queens your pawned down
and after this move knight uh
pardon me Knight to B4 you're eyeballing
Knight C2 Knight E3 that's going to be a
fork against one of your Rooks and this
is upon hanging as well everything is
gone
brilliantly I mean I just can't even say
it uh better than that everything has
gone uh Alice's Lee favorite enjoying a
great position no question about it and
by the way Carissa Rochelle again this
is a huge huge matchup and I think
Carissa is mistimed her situation when
we left it we were we had focused on the
Move Queen takes G7 you'll recall uh
Queen takes G7 Queen takes E5 was more
or less our main continuation
the move F4 just is mistined because
this move Bishop A4 comes I'm used to
saying uh with a double threat but this
is actually a triple thread right you
know because you've got the Rook back in
between he's still attacking for us I
think Carissa had it in her mind that
she was going to be able to play Rook
here and maybe she just stopped here and
said oh my next turn is I'm going to
play Knight to D4 and I'm going to be
happy and I think she's going to be very
happy uh once she gets uh to this
position so I'm thinking Rochelle is
actually for choice in this one because
there is B3 right if I go 94 there are
B3 threads with checkmates on Queen
that's what I'm thinking as well and
it's just sort of like excuse me who
invited you uh to Checkmate me uh but uh
in the junior section uh everything to
play for there Christian oh absolutely
and we have like three incredible games
going on right now take a look at this
one Brandon Jacobson versus Andrew Hong
we got to this position and we said
Knight to C3 is probably a very
important Intermezzo move because after
Knight takes E5 we have this nice little
tactic Knight to B5 first you go Queen
to B8 I take take and this in fact is a
very good position for white not winning
but definitely favorable for white this
would have been something that Andrew
wouldn't have allowed a third move
Knight to C3 we expected the move A6 and
this is where it comes uh you know your
coach often tells you be careful what
pieces you're exchanging and in this
position uh this definitely applies
because if you do take home D7 the only
thing you're doing you're helping back
black finish his development not only
that but you're also going to weaken
your king side situation as we will see
in just a second this is what happened
in the game so the best move in this
position would have been to just Retreat
the Knight to F3 we want to keep as many
pieces on the board as possible I have
more space as white on the king side
shirt on in the center is a bit equal
but it's all about this e-file the fact
that I have control over the E file the
fact that I have more space on the king
side given by The Pawn on F4 you need to
maintain pieces on the board it's going
to be much more difficult for black to
finish his development like this take a
look what happened in the game Knight to
D7 Knight takes D7 was played I don't
like this move I think this was just a
hurried decision by White Knight to C3
Bishop to C6 and right now I'm looking
at the position and I'm only seeing a
very slight Advantage for black but also
a simple Advantage for uh black in the
absence of the light Square Bishops the
king is going to be very weak due to
this Pawn overextended on F4 I don't see
any potential for an attack on the king
side G4 G5 that would be too much you
would be weakening your king absolutely
too much and you don't have enough
resources for a successful attack what
I'm seeing is a very simple plan for
black I'm going to go Rook d8 Rook D7
Rook the other Rook to d8 you can start
with the a rook you can start with the F
Rook it doesn't really matter and I see
black having an easy plan having better
placed pieces and having something to
play for and that is the weakness on D3
I don't see anything to be played for
for white just this defensive tasks
you're going to go Rook D1 Rook D2 try
to double up on default to defend the
pawn on D3 Andrew Hong is looking good
in this one I don't know if it's enough
for a big Advantage but he's just much
more comfortable right now with the
black pieces that's a crucial game as is
the game between Arthur guo and Kirk
when we left the game they had actually
played a few more more moves be
[Music]
after this position that I have on the
board Bishop A6 I really thought that
Arthur was going to go B3 here inviting
the trade and if A4 I was thinking that
we would play Bishop B2 threatening G7
that more or less provokes let's say the
move F6 now I take take and unlike the
game
I do have a pawn chain and actually in a
in a kind of a funny way because of that
pawn chain when I cast along I'm not
castling short because of the control
over the F1 when I cast along you can't
open up the queen side the queen side is
all nicely bought that Arthur didn't do
that in fact he made a mistake he got to
this position and I really really liked
Christian's offer of F6 King F7 and
suddenly when The Rook comes over you
know black is actually the one for
Choice Queen d8 not big fan of this move
it feels uh excessively slow
pardon me Christian jump in no probably
just too slow for
maybe Queen H4 Queen E4 I would assume
that's his plan
okay
yeah I think that
yeah because he was probably thinking
that uh if White's King gets away or
something he wants to play but that
looked Queen d8 perhaps aimed against
this idea of f4 right so it was that for
a threat maybe not but perhaps he just
wanted to stop F4 altogether F4 King F2
maybe this is something that he just
didn't want to see on the board F4 right
now Queen H4 is going to be problematic
so
F4 Queen H4 that's where I think he
played king queen d8 okay yes and uh the
other a key Marquee matchup game between
Mishra when we left it we really thought
that Mishra was doing uh fantastically
fantastically well uh they did reach
this position and after rooksy um after
Knight D5 Rook CA really fine move Rook
C8 and I just loved uh Black's position
my my treatment would have been to take
Bishop takes D5 we left it here and I
said
give me crazy yeah give me uh Queen C4 I
see a very very big weak Pawn on D5 I
see the that uh well I think that black
is the one in control here
something different I like the two
Bishops why do I have to give back the
two Bishops I like the two Bishops I'm
gonna preserve it by the way I also know
that he didn't he didn't even go Bishop
check
which kind of surprises me
um again I'm kind of well I am afraid of
Queen C7 obviously I would like to make
two moves at once if I could I'd like to
Castle
not that I'm I'm anxious about this but
I'd like to Castle and on a very good
day put the Knight on e4 I could Castle
put the Knight on e4 things might yet
turn into my favor if I could get the
night to E4 so my alternative to
castling would be Knight to D2 and again
if I can get my knight to E4 I I feel
like uh I'll be fighting but let's say
if you Castle first after Bishop D7 sure
can I go H5 just immediately targeting
yep that pawn opening my Rook sure and
if you try an id2 I have this like Queen
B6 move it could be a little annual for
you even the most direct of all you
could just take taken but Queen B6 I I
hear you so yeah I mean I I'm gonna have
to play Knight E2 and sorry Bishop D7
Knight D2 and H5 and you know maybe
this looks so sad it looks so sad
week whereas the blacking is enjoying a
lot of protection from its pieces
absolutely I mean and nothing nothing
on the board
nothing is threatening Black's King
Bishop E3 I think he just wants to keep
the King on E2 I mean I understand
Bishop E3 the queen B6 is a very
annoying move Bishop only three is like
in its best position exactly yes
yes so uh Bishop E3 on the board
okay uh certainly I'm not ready to give
up my uh
A4 Pawn by castling but uh what if I try
to open the position up on the king side
with H5 we a move we we love by the way
um
Christian we think the positions really
Advantage for Mishra but how big an
advantage is it according to the engines
it is it is it's almost a two-point
advantage two points yes and and does
the engine prefer uh Knight takes D5 or
Bishop takes D5 because I thought Bishop
takes D5 was Bishop positionally Splat
yes yes Bishop takes D5 done deals
it was looking really good yeah in fact
it was almost a plus three Advantage wow
okay okay so it was a significant
difference but still 25 still good still
good but uh only plus two as opposed to
plus three but it's a difficult position
for white right because we were really
struggling to find a way to hide the
king if you don't hide the king what are
you going to do keep the king in the
center probably that's what you have to
do but there is so much risk with that
strategy right
you could go King D2 at some point I
will get B5 going perhaps Queen C7 put
some pressure on the C file I have
things to do you don't
no I I agree I I just feel like
the the position the black has every
kind of trump that you would want from a
sicilian as black the one thing I would
say about the move H5 by the way
is always always always when I'm playing
uh from the opening I I feel I have
three tasks the first and most important
task is that I have my fair control of
the center as black I hear I feel I have
more than my fair control second I want
good development for my pieces and again
black has that the third thing I want is
a safe King
so when I do play the move H5 I agree
you know you're making life difficult
for black pardon me difficult for whites
King but you're also saying to Black's
King well you know you're probably not
going to Castle short you're kind of
hanging around in the center one of the
things you want to do is get a safe King
I mean you put your king over there on
the king side you know no no it's just
it's not happening and just what
Christian's saying one day B5 comes and
you're gonna have to face some serious
questions on the queen side so Mishra
looking really good tell us once more
about the game of Arthur go and Kirk
well not that much has happened well
well it was this move Queen d8 did that
spoil the situation for Kirk a little
bit by spoil you mean he had an
advantage that got reduced instead of
Queen d8 and got reduced so F6 was
supposed to be the better way absolutely
right better plan right it's all about
plans in this position nothing is
happening immediately right you have to
just arrange your pieces in the right
manner F6 King F7 E5 that was the right
way of doing things and in fact after
Bishop E3 it seems like the best move is
still F6 what I think Kirk is going to
go for uh is the Practical Queen trade
Queen to F6 look once you play Queen to
d8 I don't think you're going to go F6
it they just don't connect with each
other very well right you played Queen
d8 you look at Queen H4 Queen F6
potentially you're not even looking at
the idea of F6 that's why I think we
will see Queen to F6 from uh Kirk in
this one and the question is how do we
assess this end game okay not this one
after G6 but G takes F6 of course let's
say castle I have the E file I have the
potential of E5 not yet immediately
because I'm losing the D5 Pawn but later
on in the future at the same time I'm
looking at this point I'm seeing ideas
of f4 to stop you from going E5 Bishop
to D4 attacking this Pawn on F6 I feel
like white has something to play for at
least from a practical perspective the
engine is saying in fact that black is
better but from a practical perspective
I like White's position in this end game
at the same time Queen F6 hasn't been
played yet so we don't know exactly
what's going on through Kirk's mind what
we do know is that outside of the
opening phase Kirk has been playing
really good chess he's had some problems
getting out of the opening but once that
happens he's very practical he's a
practical player he plays fast he makes
good decisions in a short amount of time
so this is what I'm waiting to see from
Kirk as well as from Arthur go Artur has
been nothing shy of exceptional in this
tournament as you can see Arthur right
now in the cold leadership position with
abhimanyu
who is looking really good and perhaps
Arthur will need to keep Pace if he
wants to get into the tie breaks
situation thank you Christian I just
want to turn our attention in the game
of Arthur and Justin just for the visual
of what we're about to uh what we're
about to experience this is the position
after move 14 and I think we had looked
at some ideas ourselves of G5 and that
was the move that Justin played and
after Bishop G3 he followed up with the
hyper aggressive Bishop takes Knight
takes Knight E4 well you know with
thanks to this bishop on C5 I'm ready to
Pouncey tactics
sometimes they pay off right I mean
Bishop H2 H5 well let's get going you
can get our Pawn to G3 and we are
trapping the bishop life is good
Rook to E1 so he he uh Arthur is setting
up his own uh counter sacrifice that you
you play H if you play G4 I'll go HG and
then I'll sacrifice and I'll get to your
King well wait a minute let me reinforce
that night night F7 F5 and this is just
the visual you don't really see this all
in kind of approach uh but nice I know
how the Black Ink feels right now all
the defense pawns are really Advanced
but I like how you know how you are
defending the opponent E4 still
threatening G4 uh I would just make sure
that we get the queen to F6 Rook to d8 I
need to finish that development but I I
think the visual is very pretty exactly
uh there's a famous grand master from
the UK uh Anthony miles Tony
and after a move like F7 F5 Tony had an
interesting habit he liked to you know
like uh clean the squares not like
adjust the piece but he just kind of
adjust uh clean the squares and after
let's say I have played a move like F5
while I weakened the square G6 and what
he would do is go
clean the square G6 as if Queen to C2 to
G6 will Land one day and I will be
annoying
out of five it does come with some
drawbacks Kate where would you like to
take us uh what if we just look around
maybe back in the seniors Championship
because we have
um a Vladimir a copy on in an
interesting position and he's fighting
for the second place he needs to win in
his game against
now they were playing the two players
were playing this uh gruenfell Kings
Indian 95. they when we left it we left
it after uh Vladimir played in 95. it
takes takes Knight G4 Knight takes
Knight takes Bishop G5 and it looks like
one of those symmetrical positions where
thanks to the extra half move white has
the advantage type of thing takes takes
takes takes takes Brooke over so Bishop
H3 Rook takes and Dimitri's saying hey
I'm doing okay what about you because on
one hand you would be like oh that's
gonna be a draw soon but then you look
at the pieces and I like now blacksmooth
Bishop G4 by the way I've got a massive
threat in the position Rook d8 Bishop to
G4 stopping and again you're looking at
ideas of uh Bishop takes B2 but
h2h3 Bishop back to E6 and kind of
coaxed a weakness I don't know we're up
to date up why just maybe thinking about
Bishop takes B7 because that pawn is up
for grabs sure but black will be playing
Rook V8 and is happy that the B5 is
suddenly open and a lot of pawns are
hanging there are a lot of fonts hanging
I'm not sure I'm not sure I like the
move H3 I'm kind of going back I don't
like when my opponent's pieces are on my
doorstep I mean that that Rook
eyeballing I would have probably said
let let's just let's get rid of this guy
the fact that Vladimir allowed it today
I'm sorry I actually do it because after
Rook fe1 yeah maybe bishop takes B2 sure
I could do it with the other Rook too
it's a just being a little bit flippant
here are you sure you want too I do have
King G7 I don't worry about checkmates
but I do worry about that well it's just
like this pen is so nasty right you
would never really want to allow me to
just be and if I go back to GED you even
Checkmate me oops that would be very
unfortunate oh yes please sign the score
sheet
um but okay if I wanted to do it the
other way just to avoid the suggestion
that uh Bishop takes B2 I'm just saying
I want to get rid of that Rook I'm not
sure I I like that Rook uh and after
Bishop G5 we've caught up with the
players sorry I think uh this is the
position and uh I I'm saying uh gurvich
is Happy Demon's happy he's ready to
take on A2 he's ready to take on B2 uh
let's go continue around Gregory versus
Maxim
that's a very nice uh Pawn weakness to
pounce against something like this the
other day we had remember G3 I think it
was against
Andrew Hall Andrew and uh Josiah yeah I
like the setup for Gregory here
continuing with Igor and Joel I think
that this is just actually just very
fine for Joel uh it's got the two
Bishops Queen's Gambit decline Carlsbad
structure but we know these attacks with
H5 H4 are actually
[Music]
um
dangerous yeah especially six right you
are targeting those pawns on dark
squares I remember a wonderful memory I
played a match in Indonesia against
Adian to utat where I managed to get in
the sacrifice on G3 I want a very very
nice game to win the match I think Joel
is for choice in this one Patrick Wolf
versus Doug Groot
Doug has been playing some inspired
brand of chess the last two rounds in
this game it's a French defense well
with this massive what uh Lawrence day
international Master Lawrence day of
Canada my call the big clamp you know
white has the big Central clamp in the
center yesterday Douglas were playing
this like uh right so he's a little bit
complicated positions H six
G6 okay
uh from Patrick's perspective I want to
say
he uh Patrick with the white pieces has
gotten in everything you're supposed to
right age six strong night on D4 great
Bishop on D3 the only draw back to the
position is you're giving up the pawn on
C3 you could have defended it I'm not
sure if you wanted to offend it with
Bishop DT Zoo he decided to give up the
pawn queen takes check on the board uh
already on the board on the board Queen
C7 already on the board
who's who who's who's doing the gambling
did you want to say business
um
if you're in black shoes you cannot wait
to play Knight C4 and Knight B5 I'm just
wondering if I shut you down
you could get Knight C4 in but you can't
I don't know I'm wondering can I I mean
I like this idea Knight C4 and B5 or
Knight B5 but another idea could be
maybe F6
try to open the f file there
well that's playing on white side of the
board right opening up on F6 uh do you
think it is that bad yeah uh well
because you you you want a safe King
right so on a good day if you could play
Knight C
4 Knight B5 in castles your king will be
safe you can't be messed around with or
even Knight C4 and B7 B5 right if you
block it would be five let's say as you
white
you want to play B5 with white right
well first of all I'm not even sure I
don't know what I want to do let's say I
play rookie one just I mean what is my
Rook doing here right so all right then
I can go Knight C4 as long as you don't
stop I plan on the queen side okay and
the question for me is what so I'm
thinking is white I've gambited upon
from the pawn down I got to do something
you have to attack I've got to do uh so
whether I play G4 F5 or whether I go F5
right away with ideas of this I'm not
sure I'm
I'm not sure I'm doing a good job let me
be very very blunt that uh I don't know
what Patrick is intending whether he's
intending G4 and F5 and I was just
saying that I don't think you should be
reaching for this one well I'm trying to
blow things up over here on that side of
the board but okay uh
the seniors uh fun stuff that's going on
but it's all about the Juniors Christian
it's all about the Juniors and it's all
about the nerves in the first few hours
here as we are starting to understand
because take a look at what just
transpired in this one between Bellagio
and Mitra okay Mishra played the move H5
looks good perfect right you want to
open up the position potentially here
give white something to think about
right some ideas some attacking ideas
that he needs to be considering King to
E2 and now Mishra had a lot of
opportunities in the position and a lot
of good looking moves B5 was one of them
very nice immediately taking taking
advantage of the fact that the king and
the queen are stuck on this diagonal you
probably have to give up the pawn at
this point
um go Knight D2 allow me to take on A4
then try to block things with C4 it's
not good that was one of the options
another one would have been to go E4
that looks good as well that's a nice
Pawn sacrifice and it's pretty clear
that after Queen takes E4 Castle I get
the Rook on the E file you're starting
to feel the pressure feel the heat on
the E file right in fact you're close to
losing at this point
but take a look at what Mishra did he
took on G4 opening up the H file but who
are you opening up the file for right it
seems like you're opening it for white I
understand you're breaking the pawn
right you're winning the pawn you have a
big threat right now lose another move
and after Bishop to B5 you can resign
right right but if you don't do that if
you go Rook to h8 for example Force the
bishop to go back to f8 and now I just
move my king away look you're a pawn up
but I have a lot of pressure on the king
side as well
the engine is saying 0-0 at this point
wow so he blew it he blew his advantage
in the position he's going to be stuck
on the eighth rank any sort of end game
that we're going to enter you're more or
less going to be stuck right you go King
E7 I go G5 and I hold you in place on
that side of the board this one I have
to say Balaji had huge difficulties out
of the opening but finally perhaps he's
getting some counter play in this one
and take a look at what happened
in another big big Clash that is
corgis area
Bishop to E3 and Rook 2 C8 this is just
the wrong plan yeah Queen d8 Rook C8
where are you going not the combination
of moves you want where are you going
you're attacking my C5 Pawn no it
doesn't make a lot of sense right I mean
come on you're not ever going to touch
that pawn you're giving me extra moves
for absolutely no reason this Rook
should be on the B file trying to invade
via B3 right right or something along
those lines definitely not on C8 and
right now we have F6 finally doing the
right plan but now I'm able to stop you
very nicely with this move F4 and what
is the queen on d8 doing right I don't
know King to F7 we're expecting I'm
expecting Bishop to D4 and compare this
position to what we had before a couple
of moves ago G4 G5 I'm going to open you
up on this side is looking good he's
looking really good right now right
right we thought that Kirk was fighting
his way out of a very difficult opening
getting maybe even a slightly better
position but right now the last few
moves definitely have favor Arthur go he
seems to know what he's doing Kirk is
feeling the pressure and definitely not
finding the right plan
wow uh yeah and also that turn around in
Misha's game because that decision to
win the pawn you know in general you
know I love winning the pawns but in
this position where you allow your
opponent to go check and again it's this
idea that you're you know your king
position has been compromised you're in
this really unpleasant pin and
while
we understand the move Bishop B5 is a is
a major threat and King E1 is the
engine's suggestion you also start to
think about C4 what is very habitat
finally it has it had kind of threats
exactly
for a change right I've been I've been
on the back foot ever since I kind of
started the game now again if I do get
in these moves then I'm I'm beginning to
take over I guess it's the question is
is B5 and I don't know about you Kate uh
would you have taken made that decision
to allow The Rook to come to no I would
be very worried actually before before
it happened I was just saying that maybe
one thing black doesn't want to do is
open the H file but I was like yeah
that's that's kind of clear and I'm very
surprised that black clouded but one
thing I want to mention is now when we
have the current position afterwards it
takes E4 and we are saying that maybe
white is actually equalizing when we
take a look at the clock valaji is
enjoying a really nice Advantage because
Balaji has 52 minutes on the clock
whereas only 30 minutes and by the way
Mishra has been playing I want to say
strategically slowly at certain moments
remember is crazy game with Andrew that
with that French defense right uh where
he was really down to Precious seconds
uh and so he's not a stranger to uh time
trouble is uh Mishra as this
all-important game uh Marquee matchup
game is being played uh but let's just
look at the engines move for just a
moment King E1 okay so uh we we're
sidestepping the threat of Bishop to B5
when where our Queen is getting tagged
um what is Mishra gonna do
is he going to try to get out of the pin
how
take us through your approach to this
position if you were on the black side
uh Kate so I would first come to remove
life right B5 so with the idea of maybe
of posting your rook and this and
attacking also G4 Pawn right
and conversely after you've played the
move King E1 what are you hoping are you
looking at G5 and maybe on a good day to
try to uh
get in you know on Black's Camp I really
like your idea of maybe like c492 right
like transferring that night
too much more active I mean the
desirable move of course from the very
beginning is to play Knight D2 so that
you can transfer the Knight the problem
is bishopsy too I mean and you feel
terrible suddenly you know you're not
reaching for your night uh but over to
you Christian as uh we look at mishra's
uh game and take a look at what just
happened in the office before G4 is nice
I'm not sure about that this seems to be
a blunder
am I not taking that pawn you cannot
defend it with Rook G1 because I go be
special you're right you're right he
played G4 Bishop E2 is
in the books right now I mean if he
finds it first of all Becky don't play
like og5 of course I'm breaking your
whole structure you're getting killed on
the king side right so you have to go
you're almost forced to find the best
move in the position you should be too
yeah you have to go Bishop B2 I don't
think this is something that he missed I
think this is his plan and he's banking
everything on a successful attack he
says that I'm going to go Rook G1 you're
going to go Bishop F3 and now I'm maybe
just going G5
take take and we play this position next
I'm going to put the bishop on D4 and I
have a tremendous attack
but I don't see I go H6
I'm forcing you to do something to
simplify the position if you allow me to
take and then play E5 that's not good
news right that's really good for black
right so you have to do something H4 is
doesn't really work that well because
York on H1 is the uh is unprotected
right right so maybe you have to take on
F6 but then I just simply take with a
queen and finally I get my queen into
Play If I manage to get my queen into
play it's really bad news for white
right then I will be able to exchange up
to take advantage of the exchange job
man right that's where I want to get in
this position so G4 very risky decision
Bishop P2 on the board lands on the
board
whether he missed it or this is planned
because if he starts shaking his set
that's a giveaway right that's a
giveaway That's The Telltale sign I mean
the giveaway is also if you just don't
play immediately by the way uh sorry uh
because
the Mishra game Balaji just played a
shot that we I mean talking about the
risky decisions right before we have
another risky decision
eggs I mean that is allowing Bishop B5
to make a skewer exactly but I'm
actually also playing group h8 planning
to do later
exactly and I I was saying that uh check
Bishop fa King E1 B5 and I was you know
kind of referring to these ideas of G5
and Bishop H6 so Balaji he plays
F6 so his idea is if you take well now
I've got exactly what I wanted which was
this bishop H6 business right but just
what you were saying is what what
happens if I carry out my threat which
is Bishop B5
right I mean check Rook h a check and
this one we understand right I'm getting
oops excuse me you can take my queen
I'll take your queen you're gonna have
to go Queen here and I've got this
[Music]
um
pin Bishop H6 and that's not what you
want right so you take my queen
right yes I mean there's also Rook takes
C2 but probably I'm gonna
sorry I I sorry I'm going to check yes
you're going to have to move your king
I'm sorry you can't put your Bishop in
the way right and then we take
well now I have C4
you have C4 why
oh I don't because I thought I captured
the bishop with Queen yes Rook takes
yeah I capture on G7 but you have this
really strong Rook takes G4 so it's
still stopping though oh wow Rook takes
G4
uh
um tactics uh but
Mishra is looking at Bishop B5 and
saying
I can't believe my good fortune Bishop
B5 Rook h8 the bishop f8 is the blunder
right but after King D7 isn't Mishra
winning don't play that don't play
Bishop C5 Bishop B5 excuse me don't play
Don't Play Bishop B5 no no no what are
we missing oh no don't play Bishop B5 C4
Bishop B5 C4 yes Bishop takes C4 what
are we missing
D7 Knight C5
wow Knight C5
and capture on G7 that's right because
your Rook on C8 is always guarding G8
anytime I remove the bishop
wow that's really really nice tactics
nice so you so easy to fall into right
easy trap to fall in very easy so you
play Knight C5 you give away the Knight
you you learn The Rook to the bad square
and we make a queen and of course you
have to recapture with the Rook because
if you recapture with the pawn no one is
guarding the bishop on C4 okay so now
now we get it okay so F6 on the board so
what am I supposed to do go Bishop f8
then yes that's the best move oh
everything you see he's checking his
because it's 24 minutes so he has
still some time to calculate all those
lines starting to feel some pressure on
starting to feel pressure yeah yeah okay
but just a second so let's let's break
this one down so if he goes bishop f8
and I take the pawn yes I'm assuming you
have to recapture right sure and now
I've got to uh duck or sidestep the move
Bishop to B5 so I'll move my queen out
of the way hoping against hope but can I
go Bishop D7 that I've got a threat yeah
you kind of kicked me away but I'm a
pawn up right
may be attacking the C2 Pawn yeah life
is that's that's it that's the queen C4
also yeah I was dreaming that uh I would
be able to play Rook H7 and get some
kind of counter play but that's yeah
that's that's not you're not in cards no
faith is actually really good a really
good move but not only a good news
in fact decisive advantage or bad
decisive but is that also the only move
everything else is Advantage for white
everything else is well first of all the
only other movie is G takes F6 and that
seems to be giving
due to the fact that now I have finally
that H6 Square for my Bishop
it gives white some significant chances
yes
I wouldn't say that probably immediately
but at some point I will have some
page ideas
why not immediately okay
maybe you should be five Bishop B5 so in
this case I'm actually getting uh two
minor pieces for uh the position yes
okay seven Rook d8 maybe yep but you
have to be a bit careful uh do you take
on the eight was wondering can I take on
seat two now is that an option uh
I'm not sure well this is a a piece yes
you go back I take on D3 and now I'm a
you go Rook B8 how many pawns do I have
probably not enough if you start
counting
not enough not enough I've got night
yeah yeah but wow I mean this F6 at
first I thought it's a blunder but I
really like it now I mean it's kind of a
gamble but this Knight C5 move that is
so easy to miss big big gang Gamble well
it's gonna it could easily decide
the national championship title and for
Balaji when you make a move like F6 do
you get up from the board and just say
okay your opponent you know you deal
with it absolutely I make the move and I
just leave you leave how about you Chris
oh yeah absolutely yeah I'm a walker for
for the games I'm usually a walker
actually I get up almost after every
move which is terrible it's really bad
for you but
uh yeah but remember there are more
about the pressure wall so you can be
seeing whether your opponent made a move
you're going to be still analyzing the
game just not looking at the board but
looking at the monitor right
yeah and we didn't have monitors we had
these huge display boards these big big
massive uh stage and you know like they
moved the pieces with poles yeah that
that was great stuff so you could see it
from afar the move F7 and F6 and here we
see the the monitors the standings and
the players
[Laughter]
I'm sure he's very curious about the
standings and who's winning second uh as
the juniors are in the thick of things
let's just take a look at who's winning
second in the seniors by the way we have
the move in abimayo mishra's game he did
Play Bishop f8 great the best move
exactly
um let me just uh check in on uh
Vladimir's game because Vladimir he
after the move Bishop E6 he took the
bomb this is the line we analyzed yes
Rook B8 he tickled the rook and said
this is the reason why I didn't trade uh
Rooks is because I wanted this tempo and
then after Rook here I will take another
Tempo we may see your repetition right
rookie two bag Bishop F3 back except we
do have one other way of tickling Bishop
to D3
so this way
you're kind of stepping
in front of your bishop and uh plus
after rookie there's Bishop D6
oops so this move Bishop E4 may be
forcing The Rook
well well back back right didn't want to
go to C7 and walk into this one
and so this is a kind of an intriguing
position I don't know what to make of it
um not that exciting but the the race
per second is still uh thick okay big
moment in that on uh artwork let's do it
let's go because after Bishop right now
he's thinking okay I think and we've
been looking at this Rook G1 move maybe
Rook do you want to give up the G4 Pawn
but it seems another alternative move in
this position is F5
F5 if you take on D1 F takes E6 by the
way Rook D4 is on the board but F5 right
before he's on the board is on the board
oh my goodness but what do you do after
I take that point because he's going to
take that point I mean he's going to say
B and the bishop can be safely attacked
on F5 exactly right perfect square no
but Rook D4 what's happening I think his
intention is to go hunting Rook a
foreign
was going to play F4 F5 once you play
Bishop takes G4 F4 F5 is not going to
happen Kate that's the problem bad news
so I think
in blundered Bishop E2 the move Rook D4
is not the follow-up that you were the
consistent follow-up Christian that you
were suggesting whether it be G5 or
whatever it was uh yeah G4 was just
badly timed right I mean Kurt gazelle
has some kind of luck right having maybe
bad position but then turning it around
although here he started with a good
position then he got bad and now he
turned around it again well I will
everything is now going for Kirk just as
you were about to describe it you go
Rook E8 which is not necessarily that
you're tucking your king away but you
would really love to play E5 followed by
D4 then The Rook would serve nice
purpose on the C file as long as this
bishop is defending C5 there's no Rook
take C5 but E5 D4 okay but what is this
plan I'm trying to understand what his
plan is with this move Rook D4 okay you
attack my Rook oh you attack my Pawn on
A5 okay four but what if I just simply
defend it I'm gonna go Bishop D2
I I mean the only follow-up I have is
Bishop to D2 right
but no
once you've given me so many resources
on that side can I go Queen B8 get ready
for you to take
get ready to invade
yeah no I I don't I don't disagree G3
yes
it sucks really you could get that Queen
on A2 then the bishop to F5 and then you
get checkmated the light squares are so
can I play Queen before here yes Queen
A2
oh I don't have Queen c3b4 because
actually after Queen A2
or do I you're not exchanging those
Queens no no I'll go Fish by five
okay I love this uh comment that Patrick
Wolfe made about his game with Dimitri
gurvich where it was the Bishops of
opposite color he said
you know
his his dark squares are infinitely
worse than my light squares in this case
you know uh White Light squares are
infinitely worse than uh Black's dark
dark skirts and we see a rook a form of
on the board what else is attacking that
one
well yeah but just as Christians
Christian described it you're welcome to
uh Feast once that Bishop lands on that
diagonal
it looks really gross Rook A8 and queen
B8 I'm all for that's two thumbs up in
my book characters right now looking
good Arthur's in in in in trouble uh
furthermore by the way I I love Rook A8
don't get me wrong I even think that
Rook E8 and E5 and D4 also has to be
Advantage black I mean put your majority
to use and tucked your king back to G8
looks really good let's visit the
Junior's girls section we have carissaib
Rochelle mangalam Alice Lee we start
with one of those interesting position
and let's just check in on our
tournament champion actually as Alice
yeah I I thought her move Knight B4 was
going to net her in exchange this is way
back remember when we when she had this
move night before well she did in fact
win the exchange did Alice and
everything is just gone
you know sometimes you just have the
perfect tournament where it just
everything works for you in this
position black is going to play what
king D7 just to you you would love to
play Rook takes E5 but you want to stop
that Knight C6 Fork exactly so you move
King D7 first you're following that with
rookie five and or G5 by the way G G5 is
awesome you want immediately with G5
that's a yeah move as well yeah this is
painful black is a variety of choices
and they all lead all roads lead to
Victory all all roads lead to Rome here
as Alice Lee is is just what a
performance seven and a half out of nine
we can ensure and
Sharia with her pen play is a real
indication that well she hasn't resigned
but she knows uh she's about to say I've
seen enough after Rook takes H4 or
it's it's it's
on I will take with the pawn so I'm
attacking the pawn on D5
no I understand I it's just sort of like
it's one of those things when I take
away your Rook
right like I just take your Rook off the
board you have no chances whatsoever
this there's nothing for you to play for
and I leave The Rook on the board I
don't know I don't know I would play
Rook takes H4 take with the pawn Rook H4
Rook H4
GH4 you have to put your king in the way
and then like you say then you go for it
yup rookie five uh what you what what
you I just made that move yeah and G
takes and Rook H5 you just you win
everything Christian it's it's all it's
all good oh she's thinking with the pawn
okay that's what I want you know I do
too I love wh3 play Rook H5 attack on E5
the baby give me your pawns baby cafes
love it love it everything you have a
very complicated game in karisai bro
shellwoo and she's done everything that
you've prescribed yes Carissa oh there
we go yeah Shake
game over honestly with six and a half
points out of nine fantastic performance
I think more right
she started with six and a half uh today
seven and a half seven and a half by the
way where does that put her on the
rating list we haven't talked about her
rating but her rating is sorry we live
over 2 400 feet boring
is where what it does no but this is
actually unbelievable I mean she's such
a young lady I remember myself at 14 I
think I was about 2300 definitely not 24
and I immediately jumped to uh close to
GM level so this could be a complete
breakout year for Alice Lee maybe she's
going to gun for the GM title
wow that's ridiculous uh shout out to
darushi who sent an email we were asked
to give uh you know our perspective on
what Alice has accomplished at such an
early age and he said incredible that
she where she stands compared to his own
career that she stands ahead and for me
it's not even close I started late in my
career I wasn't I wasn't a master at 15.
at 15 years old I was not a chess master
that would come later so what Alice has
done and she's not an international
Master yet
elect okay so she's got it she's got the
title wants the foreign
title was the big one and after that I
made my GM Norms quite quickly I had
some difficulties making my I am Norms
but as soon as I got that you you get
that boost of confidence right when you
start playing chess as she is right now
everything is just flowing I mean you
can see it in her games even when she's
having worse positions like in that game
against Carissa she finds the best moves
she's you can sense the calm in her
moves and that can be problematic for
her opponents and we see that I mean
it's very very cool to see what
she's been able to achieve at such a
young age and the player that she's
becoming and she is
Marissa's game she was like yeah I think
her
encouraged that she was supposed to go
for a draw but she didn't and I felt
that that's when the kind of game
changed and I was starting to push in
following and that was absolutely
correct
who could have seen this who could have
foreseen this I mean you have to have an
incredible inside let's see the
prediction I see what you were setting
up could have foresee
this is very predictable what you're
trying to do yeah sir our producers lost
the graphic
our graphic designer
predictions for the junior girls
Championship
second we may have it we may have it
yeah baby
I praise I praise your Insight
well but the others tried we were in the
minority let's get to the seniors
that was it but for the juniors
everything to play for and by the way
Carissa you wanted to tell us about the
Carissa game well actually uh just to
show you a nice tactic I think it was a
few moves back at this point she played
Bishop to F5 right right uh Rochelle
that is but take a look at this bishop
to E4 was a big move in the position and
my guess is that she got afraid of F5
I understand it you see Bishop takes H6
land on the board and things are not
looking great but take a look at the
next move
B3 oh I think this is what she missed it
was a queen hanging Wally yes there's a
queen
made it what you can do is take on C8
first
right but then I take back and once
again the queen is not hanging and if
you take back with the Knight
and by the way I think I missed Queen
takes A2 at this point instead of Rook
takes C8 of course maybe but you can
start with Knight takes B3 right right
but then I go once again Queen takes it
that's pretty again you take on dito I
take on C1 I Checkmate you on B1 you
take on C8 first it doesn't really
matter I'm not giving you a check on D1
because then you return with the root
room then you're fine right right but I
take on C I think this is watching this
take on CA take on day two Checkmate on
C1 very nice variation in uh this one
she played Bishop five which gives white
tremendous chances and in fact white is
not even worse right now Rook to C6
Bishop to C2 D4 this is what we have why
this is not worse but the position
remains extremely complicated because B3
at some point D3 followed by B3 there's
a lot of pieces swarming around white
skin and there's a lot of PC swarming
around black skin as well so it's a back
and forth type of situation right now
we'll see who handles the complications
better
the problem is the time Rochelle 18
minutes 45 minutes for Carissa
definitely Rochelle has to catch up on
time because right now she's way behind
yeah big missed chance here for Rochelle
uh the fight per second is intense as
well uh let's just check in on the game
between Iris and Zoe for just a moment
when we left it we kind of left it
around these parts where it was a French
defense where you know you got rid of
your light squared Bishop so you're kind
of happy I really like what iris did by
the way her Knight on F3 was a kind of a
weak piece so she kind of moved around
it around the board and there's just
been a lot of maneuvering going on in
this game Yen's game with uh Gracie
let's just take a look at that
wow let's look at the black on town so
yeah very good very good extra Pawn very
good that's what I wanted to say as well
the first thing that caught my eye was
that Gracie is a pawn down and Rue Yang
Yan she's a happy happy camper and the
bishop is having a fantastic diagonal
right ready to support those pawns we
just need to improve the king maybe to
F6
I I could music to my ears absolutely
just improve the pieces uh King uh
I don't know I I I really like this idea
of playing e E5 and uh for E5 and F4 as
well so do I want the King on F6 or do I
want the King on
E6
um I love this position for uh for for
Rue Yang Yan and I wouldn't be surprised
if this was just a technical win at this
stage something like King E7 and maybe
A6 Bishop improve the pieces improve the
pieces and everything's going really
well but let's jump once again to the
junior section because uh crazy stuff
continues to happen Let's uh check in on
the game of Mishra after the move F6
Bishop f8 if I caught this right we're
up to date with the players and now
Balaji stopped yes 16 minutes thinking
so far
I think he missed that Bishop FH yeah
maybe he missed it maybe he undervalued
it
is a really good move and right now
Balaji is in trouble and speak to the
position tell us why uh Christian well
let's take a look at some of the main
lines uh first of all what do you do
right I'm gonna take G7 probably and
then I continue and again the onus is on
you as white you're a pond down Queen H7
let's go Queen H7 exactly but then Queen
F6
oh and the moves are not that difficult
yeah I wanted I'm just defending I'm
going to go Queen to G6 if you attack
attack me on F1 then I have Bishop B5 as
well so you still have some difficulties
with this King in the center and no
opponent for my light Square Bishop that
is the key in this position Bishop to B5
is a big big threat right right now so
Queen H7 Queen F6 in fact you're just
simply completely losing yeah that
that's the show I would really need a
knight to be on e4 please Knight C5 is
an interesting peace sacrifice but
I gave it a look and it doesn't seem
very clear to me take take and then you
just go Rook to age seven the idea of
Knight C5 is just clear yeah you want to
stop this bishop B5 right there's no
more action of The Rook on the C file
Bishop B5 always going to be met by C4
so this is uh the main idea but you're
giving up a full piece exactly you're
not getting even a pawn in return so
Rook H7 Bishop to B5 obviously not the
right move but I can just simply go back
to f8 and then you have some sort of a
slow burning initiative Queen to F5 Rook
to C7 C4 I don't see Balaji play this
type of Chess just give up a piece like
this in a must win situation in last
round with so much pressure and so much
tension
um I don't see Knight C5 happening on
the board can I uh suggest a different
uh alternative Knight C5 yes kind of
okay with F6 Bishop f8 on the board sure
Knight to C5 yeah you take I think yeah
and want to try the move Queen E4 so
okay I have the idea of the double
attack Christian
the problem is that
there's a simple way out I'm going to go
Bishop B5 Bishop B5 Check Yes and C4
right and I give my Bishop away then I
take on F6 oh yeah Bishop takes C4 Queen
takes C4 I'm like two pawns up or three
points I think I'm three points that's a
lot of points because the problem is
when I played Knight C5 I didn't play
Knight take C5
you just gave up I just gave up a piece
yeah you give the piece back two pawns
with it no problem and you started with
an extra Pawn uh yeah I think that that
uh I don't see Knight C5 happening I
think I really don't think that he's
even looking that direction the engine
is recommending an ic5 not gonna happen
um I think F takes G7 followed by
something like Rook H7 perhaps or queen
F5 first
but it just looks artificial right now
it really doesn't seem like the attack
is going anywhere
I think he missed this I think he missed
perfect
I don't know should I move my king to
just sidestep I mean this is this is not
funny is here right when you have uh
material disadvantage yeah yeah I I mean
I struggling to come up with and in fact
that's the best King D1 I mean yeah
struggling not the type of movies you
want to play when you're a pawn down and
you don't have the to be sure exactly
it's not what you call the brilliant
quiet move it's sort of like uh
really reaching uh but speaking of Quiet
Moves we have a king B1 in Arthur Gohan
kyrgazarian game by the way just to
interrupt you apologies for that but we
do have a result uh that Vladimir a copy
and Drew which I do believe uh makes uh
shapalov second clear second uh we'll
just get a confirmation of that as well
uh sorry you were saying Arthur uh made
King B1 one
simple Chess By the way I don't know you
know
Rook eighth for we were we were debating
Rook A8 and Rook E8 right but Rook A8
was uh Kirk's Choice and then instead of
Bishop D2 which kind of saw Queen B8 and
queen B3 as Christian advised uh King A1
okay hiding looking to A1 and then maybe
continuing with the same uh some
approach Bishop D2
maybe but wait now I can take the pawn
in your Bishop on G4 is hanging
apologies you're absolutely right I have
to preface it with uh Bishop to
F5 so I'm I've got
ideas of E5 and King G8 and D4 on my my
plight Arthur again tied for first with
Mishra we think Mishra is winning or at
least has a winning advantage and Arthur
while back and forth this game Advantage
has been going of it Kate uh take us uh
to where you would like us to go by the
way I'm sorry Brandon Brandon Jacobson
and Andrew Holland other crucial matchup
if
two leaders both draw the winner of the
of Brandon and Andrews game could
potentially tie for first I see this
position as balanced uh frankly a
position that is not balanced is in
Josiah stiermann and Jason Leon game
what's that
let's just understand what's happening
so many pieces in the center explosive
is what happened uh
yeah just going back and trying to
yeah uh so why this kind of targeting E6
Square the pawn on D6 is ready to run
and Knight is on the edge of the board
but ready to join the party and ready to
go D6
um
you tell me
and while you're telling me we have a
guest at studio with Christian Alice
finishing it up in style with another
crucial Victory but uh you are right now
winning your first national title how
are you feeling yeah it feels like
really great
um I've like played in this tournament
for this is my first time and to be able
to win this means a lot to me especially
since this tournament was so strong it
is so strong it's so prestigious it just
means like a really a lot for me
especially since like I worked really
hard to end this tournament I looked up
to so many people here and two wind is
just really great tell us about last
night you knew that you won the
tournament last night how were the
celebration looking like
um yeah so after I finish my game
yesterday it was pretty quick so
um I went back to the hotel and I spent
like a long time watching Chris's game
she'd make the correct moves
um and you know actually I Was preparing
for uh this game
um well I was assuming like she would
draw
um but then during that time where I Was
preparing I saw then then she was
winning so then I was like okay I can
change up the strategy a little bit
because tomorrow would just be a game
and today it was uh like I thought it
was pretty nice that I was able to win
this game and just finish the tournament
off really cleanly speaking of uh
Carissa that's another first for you
that was the first time you defeated her
one of your mentors and Idols in the
junior girls chess tell us about that
feeling accomplishing so many things in
this tournament and this year as a whole
has been amazing for you yeah definitely
um like this summer it's been really
great so far I got like my last I am
Norm in the title and then I won this
tournament so like I wasn't expecting
any of this I was just like hoping into
like just do decently I guess
um but yeah to be able to just have this
really great performance means a lot to
me it's such like a strong tournament
and it's really motivating for me to be
able to just do so well here and that
motivation goes a long way what are your
plans for the remainder of the year
maybe the beginning of next year are you
starting to think about that GM title or
is that too soon I mean I just got my
own title so like the GM title was
pretty far away but I definitely am
still like aiming to go for that title
um especially like in the next few years
it'll be crucial and
um so I think for the remaining of the
year
um I'm playing in the world team
championship and the US Women's uh I
might play like in a tournament before
the USA means to warm up and then
there's like an Isles of men uh Grand I
think Swiss franc Swiss I love man yes
so I mean I think I can actually go to
Norm there if I do well
um but you know that's like really like
hard so
um I'm just like again focusing on
improving I think I have like a lot of
time between now and the world team
championship and I'll focus on like
again like improving trying not to uh I
guess like remain where I am and go up
maybe a bit more and that's probably the
healthy way of looking at things I will
give you the opportunity to highlight
maybe the the people that helped you
along the way during this tournament
maybe thank your fans as well tell us a
bit about that yeah I'd like to thank
everybody who helped organize this
tournament and who helped me during this
tournament so first I'd like to thank my
family my coaches
um and just like everybody the same with
chess club for organizing this event I'd
like to thank all the staff here the
commentary team and also as well guys
what did we do
photography and everybody here who's
like helped my opponents were like it's
just like being here playing in this
tournament
um and listening fields and just like
everybody who have organized I'd also
like to think a chess kid who's been
like really great for me from when I
started playing chess to where I am
today and um again some of like my
previous coaches
um Grandmaster gervich who helped me I
think from when I was like seven to ten
and was like really great for my
Improvement
um just like there's so many people I
have to thank for everything that I've
been able to like achieve so far
um and I'm just really happy that I was
able to do this Alice big
congratulations guys any questions for
our champion yeah absolutely Alice
congratulations really fantastic
performance in this tournament great job
on winning this title my question is you
know a lot of people have a lot of hopes
for you right you are winning this
tournament so young you are just 13
years old and this tournament is for
girls under the age of 20. so big
achievement but you already played
really well in the American Cup in the
U.S Championship you also have the
international Master title your imelect
so I'm wondering there could be a lot of
pressure on you how people say you know
the Great American talent how do you
handle that yeah that's a good question
so firstly like I try to set my own like
before like people who are saying like I
should become a great math in the next
two years or something I just started
like my own goal which is to uh just
like improve and
um generally I try like not to focus on
what people are saying and there is some
pressure involved
um but mostly just like focusing on it
is more helpful than like going under
the pressure to become really good
because again I think the less pressure
I have on myself the better I'll be able
to perform
absolutely and Alice I just want to say
that I had predicted that you were going
to win I couldn't I didn't ask Kate to
join me but I couldn't convince
Christian Christian
that's the truth don't throw me under
the bus yes sir I see what you're doing
there uh congratulations Alice really a
dream come true for you and uh well
we're all proud of you well done thank
you absolutely as here we have Peter
Master Alice Lee the 2023 U.S junior
girls Champion again fantastic
performance fantastic year of chess for
her and she wins six thousand dollars as
well as a ten thousand dollar uh
scholarship to any University of her
choice and the tickets to the U.S
women's championships absolutely
and uh well that's woof that was fun
what a tournament it's just it's just
amazing uh let's go to the Juniors and
uh what is going on with Arthur versus
Kirk and we left it Arthur was a
favorite to pick up the pawn on A5 which
indeed happened but just as
um Christian predicted the queen coming
down to B3 and uh well
what do you think about these uh apples
I I mean it has to be winning for for
black I don't know if we should start
with Rook B8 first or do we want to you
know reposition
to to nail the King right so let's say
uh Rook ba Ruby yes okay now I'm more or
less I've got to block the B file I
close my eyes and hope I've got you know
stuff right can I go Bishop F5 checks
yeah and it's super super painful
D3 and my only hope is just to transfer
the bishop to C4 and check with you
it looks absolutely absolutely atrocious
so let's take a look at the standings
for a junior and if Arthur were to lose
this game
and Mishra were to win he's got it he's
that that's that tournament over and
make sure it draws then only Brandon uh
or Andrew could possibly that means no
playoffs
yeah just saying a lot of important
games here players really need to find
the best moves we're gonna take a break
and we'll see on the other side of the
Sprint
[Music]
thank you
I think just the biggest thing is just
to you know love the game you know
that's the big thing why I've continued
for like so many years now
um yeah just finding passion what you
love you know there's always times when
like chess feels kind of boring or you
just don't want to stare at it for hours
and hours
um but always what keeps me coming back
is just that I love the game I love
winning and yeah hopefully I continue
that here
um well I would say you have to love the
game because if you don't have any
passion then it's very hard to improve
so first learn to enjoy the process and
then once you've figured that out you
can improve quite easily for me at least
for me when I was growing up I was just
playing the game just for the passion of
it I didn't really have any clear goal
in mind and um I'd say the same just uh
play the game if you enjoy it you don't
know where it'll take you and just uh
see how it goes I would tell them to aim
high but I wouldn't say to chase that
goal too much I would say just focus on
improving whatever you need to improve
at the time and just try to play For the
Love of the Game not for like a title
you might be chasing or a rating you
might want I'd say the first main thing
in in order to become better at
basically anything is to enjoy the game
otherwise everything will feel like
torture so my advice is enjoy the game
and work on the areas which you feel
that are not up to up to the mark and
yeah work hard and everything else will
come your way
I think the big thing is you have to be
self-motivated I know a lot of young
players you know their their parents
push them a lot which is a good thing um
but I think in the end the people who
make it really far are the ones who are
always hard on themselves and pushing
themselves to be better regardless of
what level they're at so I think that's
the number one thing just that sort of
attitude of being tough on yourself and
nobody's pushing yourself to get to that
next level well I mean I've solved
around 1200 or 1300 hours of Chess Tempo
when I was a kid and that helped me
immensely and uh one of the things I
regret was not having a solid repertoire
from the beginning um during my game so
it's very important to play very solid
openings from the beginning of your
chess career because if you get an
opening trouble uh repeatedly you'll
find yourself under more problems during
the game in early in your career you
should try to be familiar with different
positions for example and also like
different approaches I think it's really
important about really enjoying the game
enjoying playing enjoying sewing puzzles
enjoying practicing and especially with
availability of resources nowadays with
streamers engines all these resources
it's not hard to improve but I think
it's important to kind of find that
motivation when you begin to kind of get
better and more you enjoy the game of
course the farther you'll go I think
like passion and trust is very very
important especially for young kids and
so I love that these days there's so
many resources to to get into chess like
YouTube You've Got streamers like Gotham
chess and ikaro who you know are fun to
watch and I think the problem that kids
face is that they get bogged down in the
opening Theory or these like theoretical
things that they feel like they have to
know but it's important for them to
First just learn the the fun things
about Chess the tactics the fun the
exciting the attacking chess so I think
that's the most important thing
foreign
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
hello I'm women's Grandmaster William
tokurjonova I will be doing social media
for the U.S Juniors and seniors chess
championships follow us in our social
media and get more exciting behind the
scenes action
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen singfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomed chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
hello I'm women's Grandmaster William
Tucker jonova I'm doing social media for
the US Juniors and seniors championships
here in San Luis follow us for more
exciting behind the scenes content
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varusha nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 200 and 50 000
Scouts earning the badge since 2011.
students of chess can also pick up a
copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen
sinkfield anyone can learn how to
understand chess notation in no time we
view chess as a valuable educational
tool learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
foreign
and welcome back to our live coverage of
the National Junior Championships we'll
start with some results we have one
result in the girls section Alice Lee
confirmed her championship title she won
against Shreya mangalami so impressive
our big congratulations to you and how
about in the seniors in the seniors we
have two results but peaceful drugs
shabalov Drew with Katya a copy I'm Drew
with grevich and the standings and the
Juniors is everything to play for still
on the table in this one we have a
two-way die for the first place abimano
Mishra and arturugo with two and half
points but closely behind is Brandon
Jacobson Andrew Hong and Balaji dagupati
with Five Points well let's just jump
right into the games and let's start
with the Balaji versus Mishra game
because when we left it we really
thought that well Mishra was doing
incredibly well F6 Bishop f8 very
important move right he was very happy
to see that on the board yeah this is
where uh Bellagio
I'm in trouble uh I'm a pawn down but
I'm facing this massive threat of Bishop
B5 pinning my queen to the king I'm
losing takes first on G7 Bishop takes
and King D2 now we just like thought
everything was going to be good for
black including this move Queen F6 but
the engine disagrees that it feels like
that that was not a precise move that
after Queen E4 well this um there's
something going on uh suddenly there's a
movie you really liked it characterized
the queen to block the pawn on E5 and to
attack the bishop exactly one of the one
of the things I this move Queen F6 does
suggest even though maybe you don't want
to do it right away it does suggest
you're ready to blast open the diagonal
Queen E4 uh hitting the bishop on A4 and
well I mean Mishra is still ahead of
material and look at the clock Mishra
has less than eight minutes to make 16
moves right and that's quite nervous
but it still has 23 minutes so a serious
time advantage uh jump in on this one
Christian oh it's all about the time
right now for sure because you have so
many options as black and this is
exactly why Mishra has been spending so
much time on his decisions you can go P5
in this position you can go Bishop to B5
you can do a lot of things obviously it
is black for choice right you don't have
a clear attack as white you are a pawn
down the question is just how much
compensation do you have and how will I
convert this uh advantage that I have
that I'm enjoying for quite a while as
black queen to C7 by the way was a much
better move in the previous move Queen
F6 Queen to E4 it's all about the time
this is what abimanio needs to focus on
he cannot let the nerves get to him
because right now it's all about the
nerves but
you know what's playing in his favor
what's that even with a draw in this one
he might clinch the title because
ardurgo is completely lost wow wow look
at that one okay take a look at that
game that one is just busted
foreign by the way he is also down
severely on time he's struggling to find
the plan and it's very easy for black so
you like this area V8 move right when we
lived in The Rook threatening Checkmate
on B2 yeah it's a bishop coming to D5
and there's some very nasty things
happening on those light squares around
Queen C3 again whenever you have the
situations where you're going to trade
Queens you always ask yourself the
question who's attacking the king and in
this case white is like please please
let's trade Queens no no no no no says
Kirk Queen A4 King A1 D4
I really really love to get in uh D4
first of all it's uh pushing a pawn with
a gain of tempo and more importantly
it's giving the bishop uh access to this
diagonal yeah
Queen B3 Queen
it does exactly look this is it this is
over I'm telling you exactly how it's
going to finish how's it going he's
going to go with Rook G3 okay to stop
he's not going to go B4 almost no way
he's gonna go B4 yeah I don't see him
playing before right Rook B3 Rook boy
three yeah that's it
you're getting checkmated well I got
this queen B1 recovery and then you're
going to be paralyzed completely exactly
Christian your prediction is coming true
it's the natural way it's the natural
way of playing and I can guarantee you
Kirk already knows what he's doing he
wants to play Rook to B3 he knows he
needs to eliminate the only defender in
the position for uh White that is The
Rook on G3 right right
let's see
and by the way for Arthur this is like a
nightmare it is I mean you know he's
played a marvelous marvelous tournament
he's put himself in position to win the
US junior Championship qualify for the
national championship Rook B3 on the
board and to throw away an opening
advantage that he had after Queen C7
this is really really really painful
it's nice it's difficult last round you
know how much is at stake exactly guys
right let's get back to Mishra because
he just sacrificed the piece say what
what he played Queen G6 I can take on A4
foreign
what is like what in the world is
happening B5 uh you're going to take
something on C2 so I'm going to take on
A6 right to attack The Rook attack D6
attack B5 a lot of attacking with
capturing upon
you had me capturing upon that was
excess you know all of those captures
captures captures
um Jump Right In Christian what on Earth
is going on we didn't see Mishra
sacrificing his Bishop no no no and I'm
looking at the eval and it's saying
zeros
you're getting your beloved zeros but
maybe Mishra is winning the tournament
with the zero draw he wins the
tournament I don't know if he knows it
perhaps he has Andrew or Jacob saying is
still in the running they could if there
if there was a decisive result but that
looks like a draw and what exactly the
The Jacobson versus uh Andrew Hong is
that's the one that you were talking
about right yeah yes
but this one is very equal it's
extremely extremely equal I really don't
see on any of these players win this
position
equal material why very slight
imbalances in the position I don't see
why is mishra's game zeros according to
the engine because that's a big one
right yeah right
Queen takes check okay B5 I have to go
B5 only Queen takes A6 Queen takes A6
right Queen takes C2 Queen takes E2 I
can take with the Rook as well but I
think Queen takes is just more and look
at look at Mishra he has six minutes but
he knows what he needs to do I think
he's going into Arthur I think he's
going to see what Arthur is doing
he probably realizes the fact that
he only has a Perpetual at the end of
things and remember in his interviews he
always reminded us that second place and
last but nothing it's only if I can be
first exactly if I can so he's gonna go
all in he's gonna try to gamble but
maybe when he realizes that Arthur go is
losing then he understands he wants that
U.S Championship spot sure it's so
difficult to get it the rating
requirements are so high right now look
at him look at him watching and he's
looking into the other positions too he
has to quickly calculate their position
and then he can get back to his own but
first Brandon where's Brandon and Andrew
and what's happening in the Arthur guo
game that's what he's asking himself
right now well but I'm asking you what's
happening in balaji's game because I
still don't understand why it's triple
zeros
yeah Quincy takes C2 forcing with King
E1 yes right and now you do where's your
queen bee one Queen B1
King F2 Rook C2 and now Rook C2 okay
this is the point now I'm just trying to
take the rook and you're going to give
me a perpetual
uh so after I play Knight D2 you're
going to take the rook and I'm gonna
give you a Perpetual yes wait what is
the perpetual so
let's take on B5 right maybe
you capture King E7
the question is if you can
start running yeah on um
shoot check
yeah let's go check first that's an
important move even though I'm not sure
it's necessary perhaps not that easy to
calculate
um no F6 now I think is
Queen B7 king of fate
that's the thing I still don't know why
it's a Perpetual okay okay
so you want to go to F6 I think let's
get the king to F6 so Queen takes A4
check by the way has not been played
this Balaji have a an alternative to
this no no I don't think he does I mean
why if it doesn't then he's just a
Ponder I mean he still has 16 minutes on
his clock so he just wants to make sure
you know
Queen takes a 6 first of all I can also
take with the Rook but let's go Queen
takes Queen B1 let's say kingy two Rook
c292.
I kind of like the King on E2 for white
okay
if you really want to Knight D2 takes on
H1 yeah I take on B5 right and now let's
say you try to escape my perpetual and
you go to F6 right
so Queen B7 check King F6 no I just go
Queen D7
I think this force is some sort of a
massive reaction
I have a Checkmate in one thread oh gee
right where's your oh Queen takes D6
okay
oh but Queen F5 is a double attack on
The Rook on the Rocks
I was I was so focused on saving my king
I wasn't focused on uh losing my rock oh
my goodness what a finish to this uh
tournament
crazy
um and by the way uh in this in this
variation this line where you go Queen
takes A4 check B5
no it doesn't make any sense I was about
to offer uh alternative move Queen A3
but I don't see
why that would be any Improvement so it
looks like a very forcing line in fact
Queen takes A6 Rook take check
check
okay let's try to go Rook take C2 maybe
that's the more testing way okay
by the way they say four on the board B5
immediately Mishra was at the board he
wasn't at the monitor he was at the
board and queen takes A6 okay the place
is like okay I'm grabbing your piece
grabbing your pawn and this is the
moment you were about to suggest Rook
take C2 and Christian take us through
just a quick Interruption we have a draw
between
um
yeah Gregory kaidanov and Maxim blogie
yeah he's very happy about it yeah yeah
they're happy the tournament's finished
and they can just relax a queen takes it
Queen takes you too expected I think he
we're going straight into that variation
with uh the capture of The Rook on H1
and that will be the Perpetual check you
were talking I have a feeling that
Mishra just simply uh
knew that Arthur is losing before he
made this decision to go Queen G6
wow if so
serious yeah if if he actually did that
we will ask him but that's a very
experienced move right there but I feel
like he was sitting at the board the
whole time I
it always feels like that right but
whenever we're not watching whenever
we're on a break so maybe he goes uh he
goes away
you see Queen to B1
clearing that C2 Square for a rook yes
just
to update everybody on the current
situation is Mishra wins
he wins the tournament yeah well if
Arthur doesn't win well we Arthur way to
be predict he's not gonna win so yeah if
Mishra wins he's going to be the U.S
junior Champion what is the water but
Mishra is not winning Mishra I think is
making a draw so and we're anticipating
after Queen B1 check King E2
by Balaji again you can take the Rook
without first
um making a check because the Rook on C8
is hanging Rook C2
we we block the check with the Knight
Knight D2 We Take The Rook now we're in
exchange up and that is why white starts
looking to try to make a Perpetual check
with a series of checks forcing the king
to escape via F6 if black continues to
play for trying for a win which in this
situation may not even happen exactly
and uh
we don't
want to
walk into a queen F5 check and picking
up the Rook on C2 oops that would not be
suggested
um wow and how bad is the Arthur game uh
Arthur Go versus Kirk because when we
left it we thought it was terrible yeah
well he he's not getting checkmated yet
let's just put it that way it's yes
yes as as good as you want to call that
um Queen do you want Queen to C4 I think
you've just taken them C4 and then go
King to B1 perhaps this is the way to
run
Queen to C4 with the threat of Rook G3
and queen A2 mate
get out of it I think take on B3 first
pardon me take on B3 first
right now we've got to get up uh Queen
B1 we just paralyze ourselves we we
can't move any further so King B1
wait can I play D3 here
oh you sir and I'm giving some squares
right and D3 Bishop C3 and somehow
you're hanging on by a threat
by a thread
feels like one of those positions where
you really should be uh utterly and
completely lost my idea was like
somebody asked them to Checkmate Queen
A2 Queen A1 right and get rid of that
escape square but it looks quite as fine
why this I mean fine uh meaning not
getting checkmated right right all right
and we see by the way in the Mishra game
um Rook c292 Queen H1 was played so
we're going well bolt we're bolting into
that variation going back and forth
between these two key
matches and uh by the way I'm just gonna
refresh my board with the Mishra and
they have played up to Queen takes H1
and here we are expecting Queen
give a check and a prepared perpetual
wow that'll be amazing accomplishment
for abhimanyu winning this championship
and getting that ticket to U.S
championships
who on Earth could possibly have
predicted that in a very unexpected way
right I mean you'd have to be a prophet
Queen takes B5 check by the way on the
board but for Balaji I mean obviously
you know he would love to have won this
game with white and been in that
contention to go to the national
championships but
he he basically saved this game because
it looked terrible uh
for a moment there and you know last
year he tied for third in the U.S
Juniors and this year I think if he
makes a draw he may tide for a second
second uh again depending on Arthur's
the outcome of Arthur's uh game Queen
takes B5 and if Kirk wins this one I
mean Mishra really needs to buy him
dinner
with the black pieces in the last round
are the worst opening yeah that Queen C7
move that was a terrible setback for
Kirk an opening howler just showing that
he didn't know exactly what to do he
didn't know the theory but fighting his
way back but as he has been doing this
whole tournament by the way wait uh Kirk
did a play that nice move Queen C4 it's
on the board and Arthur's suffering here
and he's enjoying Kirk also nice time
Advantage Kirk has 20 minutes on clock
whereas Arthur go only four you know
what the sad situation is if you take on
B3 and you go King B1 and you go into
this line that we were discussing
D3 Bishop C3
now I can just simply take your Pawn on
H2 Queen C2 and queen takes H2 that's a
good Pawn that that is a great part
then the eight seven Pawn just
unstoppable that's right
he's going into that variation by the
way
he did take and the problem is why
doesn't have really counter attack you
can play before because you just clear
the second rank for a Checkmate you
cannot push these things okay he's not
going for that he's going for Queen A2
he went Queen
so after King B1 Queen A2 check right
away
I mean he can be thinking about Queen C4
and then playing D3 right kind of
looking at that C5 Pawn potentially F4
Pawn maybe that's what he wants yeah
that's a good point Queen C4
C1 Queen C4 and then D3 and Bishop C3
you take the pawn on F4
okay and pause pause Bishop B3 no Quincy
for check no no sorry
should be three oh right now
and threatening me ah Queen E4 at first
I didn't see how am I supposed to defend
mates I mean if I move my Bishop I just
checking the queen E4 and that does
defense that's somehow a way to give
your opponents yeah right I mean because
if you don't see Queen E4 or you just
think to yourself I'm mating my opponent
sorry Kate you were about to say queen
C4 check yeah Queen C4 is the move I
like here just forcing the king back to
be one okay and then D3
somehow that's kind of transpositional
right but that now I can take on F4 yeah
so you don't have this bishop C3 instead
of taking on H2 and you can play like
Queen C1 because that just blocks that
last Escape square and there is a
Checkmate and by the way the move D3
does threaten mate
it does threaten uh check and made so
I'm virtually
forced to give up the F1 which is more
important than the H2 Pawn they must say
and uh is is the clock a factor for Kirk
no Kirk has 19 minutes which is plenty a
lot of time given he needs only four
moves to make okay and Arthur has five
minutes we haven't checked on it for a
while Brandon uh Jacobson versus Andrew
hung again we've been basically saying
yeah it's balance balance balance but in
this last move uh B7 B5 by Andrew is an
indication that at least he's trying uh
to win the game
um and I think Mishra is signaling that
he's not going for
King F6
it's not going for kids
he's ready to take a pipette perhaps we
should go to that position just yes we
may see a handshake very soon check
check
seven still one last chance to maybe go
to F6
I think if this was round two maybe
Mishra would go for it if you have six
you know to attack I mean not to attack
we just try to go on in this game and
continue and maybe play for a win but
right now he doesn't need to he saw the
positions he saw the other positions he
knows what's happening
and he probably knows understands the
fact that
king of faith is just going to
potentially give him the championship
I mean if he if he needed to play for
the win he could give back the exchange
and take on D5 but he doesn't
Gamble
why to do that like there's nothing to
prove right you win with the
championship with a draw yeah you're not
sure you're you're still not sure until
the last moment until the score sheets
are signed right at the same time you
have an amazing chance to potentially
clinch right now
yeah keep in mind that he has only uh
two and a half minutes two minutes
that's right eight moves
I'm expecting King E8 I kind of feel he
wants to play King F6 but I don't like
that choice for him
I feel it's a bit too risky
it is he's he's truly a fighter but he's
he's very good when it comes to this
making this type of decisions
very experienced
King E7 yes
or
um
because he is probably about to claim
three uh claim drops Queen B7 threefold
repetition and we might be seeing our
first result in the Juniors a crucial
result in the junior section right now
mine is just confirming
that it is a three-time repetition yeah
Myers she has a lot of experience in
this tournament yeah I mean how many
claims need every single round
and we have seen some false claims by
the way as we are on our ninth day
broadcast we'd love to shout out our
thanks to everybody at the World Chess
Hall of Fame Shannon Bailey Emily for
everything they do to make the
tournament go so smoothly no yeah it
looks beautiful in the place are
enjoying it absolutely and here at the
St Louis chess club with the Scholastic
Center a big shout out to everybody here
who makes our life so wonderful and
happy Genie and Rex thank you so much
for all your support joy and Tony of
course and everybody on staff Rebecca
Emily Ryan uh boy I'm gonna forget
everybody Caleb exactly I'm going to
forget everybody
thank you
thank you the production team uh
especially a big shout out to our
production team our graphic artist who
always gets my predictions perfectly
right
you everybody's terrific and to
yourselves as well I mean really really
nice Kate I know this was our first
broadcast together I hope we come back
it's been it's been fun and even with
Christians Christian's been absolutely
fantastic I know yes we are not gonna
admit it a little shaky little but
uh but it was it has been a great it's
been the the national championships they
always bring out so always the best
always fun players look we have three
incredible championships exactly and uh
everybody's here to fight everybody
knows that that first spot especially in
the Juniors and the Junior games because
that gives you a ticket to the U.S
championships right right so these are
coveted titles and you can see it in
every single round everybody's here to
fight we get exciting games we have a
lot of fun here in the studio so and
that's what it's all about and really
seeing the best young talents of
American
but again like Iris Simone also very
young player a lot of just very young
players in these tournaments yeah
absolutely yeah it's great let's just
turn our attention now that uh Mishra is
in The Dugout he's finished uh he's
looking at the game of Arthur and Kirk
is are we and we're just seeing this
position after the move King yeah Kirk
is following the line we were predicting
and now just D3 very strong moves right
mate yes Brandon have one minute on his
clock does he let's take a look is that
correct wow yes one minute on his clock
against six minutes on Andrew hung's
Clock uh he has 15 moves to buy the way
this is Carissa's game we look like we
have a result I think Harissa won her
game against Rochelle wow what a
comeback in that game wow wow wow and we
now go back to the brand
30 seconds and counting I mean he
doesn't look like he's ready that he
played on like 30 seconds increments but
he doesn't look like he's ready to move
either uh so I mean he could take on the
east side right whoops sorry yeah
Christian what what were you saying you
can take on B5 or take on A7 right those
are two moves right I I was thinking the
safe for move was to take on A7 but
maybe I'm trying to understand wait a
second Brandon 10 seconds
decide you gotta do something and he did
it with seven seconds on his I was about
to say that's the safe move but you were
looking at takes on B5 as well
ouch but this one slightly worse I take
on D3 I take on C4 yeah this is going to
be slightly worse not much worse right
but
something to play for uh and now 87 can
I do
no Rook D7 to make a pin Maybe
takes D3 Rook takes D3 we're expect
B5 takes C4 look I don't think there's
much to play for not but if somebody's
playing it has to be black there's
something
and 13 moves left for it with a minute
on the clock
and any win any winner in this game
between Brandon and Andrew means a
playoff with Mishra provided of course
Arthur
doesn't score
right we were looking at Arthur Go and
Kill gazarian but this game is also very
important we thought it's going to be a
draw but if it's not then Mishra will
have to play this was really good
calculation by Andrew take a look at and
this is I'm starting to understand why
he spent so much time on this decision
if you go back a few moves
okay what if you take on B5 right right
if you take on B5 I go Rook D2 Rook C2
excuse me Rook C2 check and now the only
move is to go back with the King if you
go Rook D2 which to my eyes makes the
most sense right you take take
Bishop to B4 Rook to D3
Bishop to C5 is one way but I'm not
convinced that after Bishop takes C5 and
Bishop takes A7 uh you're doing okay
with uh with black but what you can do
after Rook D3 is G5
G5 well E5 I take take and I have Rook
F3 right that's a very important chart
so you play G5 first I take on G5 and
now E5 and that wins wow this is really
good calculation
by uh by Android I have to say
so we see btech C4
so uh the current position is Bishop
takes A7 Rook D3 Rook D3 B takes we're
anticipating Brandon recapturing if we
play a move like Rook to C3 the problem
with Rook A8 turns the tables on us we
think we're we're putting them in a pin
we're getting scared actually
um
yeah okay
actually that's not true what I'm saying
I can actually play Rook C3 Rook A5
Bishop F2 Rook takes A2 and take C4
but okay I think yeah we're gonna get
the same position uh but this one is a
bit tricky because I have Rook B2 at the
end and I win a pawn uh-huh
so we're going to get 10 seconds guys he
needs to make a move again now he went
down last time he went down to seven now
it's just a simple five so takes and we
because our F4 Pawn is hanging we're
anticipating Bishop to E3
and uh by the way we have two winners uh
in uh Arthur's Arthur Zhu lost to Justin
Wang and by the way Josiah steerman
defeated Jason Liang so uh shout out to
those two players for their wins in this
Championship round Bishop E3 on the
board defending we're anticipating Rook
to
um A4 kind of and wow
yeah white will be in a passive position
but because the it's such a reduced
material uh Christian we're probably the
engines are just only saying slight
Advantage black yes yes only sliders
very very close to zero zero very close
yes okay I would say practically zero
zero okay so it goes back to Arthur and
Kirk for a moment right but let's just
just see he's kind of repeating the
position
has he has been repeating it for quite a
few times no no kidding Queen D3 chance
really going there
to the world but
at this point he has to make he has to
do something different
he needs to go D3
it's not just uh
take the part on H2 and be happy with
the loot
I I like that whole uh Queen uh C4 and
D3 variation can he but I wouldn't go
for it right now I would be worried
about three times
exactly this lady free make sure you
know you don't uh accidentally make a
draw I've done that too
I thought I was being very clever and
allowing picking up some time on the
clock something I would never have done
if they hadn't changed the time controls
I mean the bonus the whole Bobby Fischer
bonus uh came in much later in the late
1980s
all right I'm gonna okay now I need to
check it King C1 okay this is at least
twice
but it's not three times yet it's not
it's not three times yet but after King
C1 Queen C4 is three times right no it's
not it's also twice
yeah I see Queen C4 once only it's also
just twice wow I mean I'll wait for here
he's playing with fire he's really
playing with fire I have to say but
whatever I thought that you have to
do the same moves and then I was you
know I did not repeat the same moves but
then my opponent claimed it but it was
the same position repeated and that's
important by the way our tour is
probably checking he's like oh okay how
many times did we do this right honestly
I would claim this if it was my game if
it's incorrect it's incorrect fine
Arbiters are gonna tell me that but he's
looking I mean he's really hoping that
that it would be true the only thing the
punishment if you claim incorrectly is
that your opponent is gonna get two
minutes and that's a trade-off I would
be willing to make here clearly I mean
uh two extra minutes
let's go back to to this Andrew really
let's go back to this one because this
is Andrew honk this is not that easy
okay what happened there by the way we
do have E5 on the board
after Bishop E3 E5 has been played
can I take and go F5 and hope for
something why not
I mean you have to go for it right right
at this point we take on F5
and now with the move F5 black has an
intact Pawn structure White's rather in
tatters I must say and your opponent has
40 seconds on his clock and King 26.
that can be I like this I think that
this is a great uh great attempt maybe
if I was getting somewhere with with
black yeah if I was in white shoes and
Brandon's shoes I might have chosen to
play King to G
just to avoid this this is
this has some promise in my opinion for
white uh for for for for black I tend to
agree yeah two minutes
okay so what he can do
is in fact Rook to D4 this can't be
right they've only played 30 moves
they're going to be playing 10 more
moves both players down underneath the
minute very little time on there boy
they have played slowly haven't they to
go okay so what he wants is probably
Rook D4
Rook G4 King F3 F5 and now Rook D4
and then Rook D4 oh The Rook is kind of
almost trapped it doesn't Force
G6 if necessary G6 and maybe root D7
right
something like that
Jesus yeah there's there's some certain
awkwardness about Black's pieces because
you really you desperately want to play
King E6 and Bishop G5 now as as fast as
possible but
you've got Bishop C5 Bishop to G5
uh stopping me and so it means that
after Rook to D7 I'm forced to move my
king
they took it okay G4 F5
he's going for this imbalance where he
I'm not sure if you're allowed to do
that because he played one of his move
then his opponent made a move then he
moved another
but you cannot have three moves
Unwritten exactly you're supposed to
write your your moves uh sequentially
yes
um guys I mean look if you don't find
the best moves right now with white you
might end up in trouble oh with no
question if you give black the chance to
play Rook A4 with the gain of that Tempo
followed by King E6 I think you're done
and dusted Andrew would win this game
so that's why I think that this move
Rook D4 so
crucial right here
it's crucial yes
and it's not easy that's the thing
well if I'm in white shoes and I'm
seeing Rook A4 okay
I I'm thinking I'm lost so I have to
find the move Rook D4 because the
Alternatives lose and I think this is
the draw so you just forced as black to
drop your Rook back nothing else to be
done and once again it looks a little
bit misplaced you you you you're
desperate to play Rook A6 and King E6 so
I have to Rook D7 uh as we're saying
there's a there are two ideas
back with the bishop that and game is
lost right
yes exactly so this is a winning threat
in fact Bishop C5 and so we changed all
the pieces we have two pawns that are
running right
seven five
now he's a little bit
worse guys but King he ate right no King
E6 King E6 sorry and after Rook I don't
know G4
back to G4 it's simple so I don't have
Bishop F4 because of G5 oh man this is
getting dicey right now this is not easy
anymore the computer is saying that
black is doing really well okay not
winning by any means yet
but good chances after King to E6 really
good chances I I have to agree I mean
again if you look at the structure and
you see these scraggly pawns the pawn on
E5 H2
um
conversely you know these very nice
structure for black
where
three verses are we in fact going to see
Andrew Force the tie breaks like this
right oh this would be a scripted finish
I have to say
now let's uh just take it from the top
if Andrew were to win
and we think he's closing in on
precisely that he would tie with Mishra
and there would be a playoff that was
the money move Rook to G4 that was it
and what a turnaround this has been for
uh
for Brandon it's time for Brandon to
start pushing A4 and hope you have to
find your own counter play because you
know what black is aiming at that is to
push the pawns on the king side pick up
the pawn on E5 exactly and he has to go
for A4 but on the other the problem with
as I see it with A4 is this move Rook E4
is coming with the tempo I take the
bishop that's that's right with a check
so A5 would be a big blunder here right
A5 Rook takes E3 and that's painful
the old double attack and probably after
rookie four you have to go Rook A8 right
okay Rook A8 and we we can pick up this
Pawn with uh yeah you pick up that guy
and I continue pushing right I think I
need my Rook behind
behind and keep pushing
and time to push as well right and now
do I have rookie eight
Rook E8 yes because you have to defend
your bishop and then I'm in time for A7
exactly I have to do it uh okay that a
pawn is dangerous also
um yeah because you get the A7 that's
protected by the bishop it's it's
basically the perfect
setup okay so uh Let me refresh my board
sorry everybody and how is Arthur
getting along it's bad bad no three-time
repetition in that game by the way yes
that's bad Kirk is doing incredibly well
A4 move 35 on the board king move 35 yes
and suddenly for the first time Andrew
he's getting down on the clock he's
relying on his increment and he did play
rookie four before he sets up for that
Rook takes E3 Cheapo Rook A8 uh we don't
expect Brandon to fall for that and no
we don't
but he can't give a check on a six inch
I've got a nice idea okay G5 all right
because the problem is G4 check where do
you go with your king
two Bishop H4 check
so you don't G5 and you don't have time
for A5 that's a good one that's that's
like it 13 seconds
ticking ticking and he moved his Bishop
by the way he's just he just sidestepped
a lot of those tricks with Rook takes E3
check he played Bishop
to B6
this is dicey
really dicey for a while I mean you're
still on the edge
but I mean it's so close It Feels So
Close from getting in big trouble uh in
fact I'm I'm finding myself really drawn
to this whole idea of G5 and G4 right
now you start seeing some checkmates
right who follows here yeah that's right
yeah the the The Mating net suddenly
magically appear you gotta go H3 now
because G4 check and Bishop comes here
and there could be a mate on the first
ring you have to go H3 H3 is crucial H3
yes you have to at least provoke the
exchange of one pair of pumps like if I
go H5 you're ready yeah well I think
you're ready to you'd be happy to trade
the the H2 Pawn I don't know
five seconds H3
because he found the best sequence of
moves to stay oh my goodness oh my
goodness the only way to stay in the
game this is the Grand Master Level
chess right few seconds left on the
clock oh he played uh G4 I wasn't
thinking he was gonna take the pawn on
E5 and play Rook to B5 in order to keep
the H Pawn on the board he didn't he
just went straight to go King G3
download King G2
no King G2 F4 exactly that would be
lights out you have to stay on G3 but
that was the problem King G3 I would
have left the H5 and H3 pawns on the
board if I were in black shoes I would
have just taken that pawn immediately
but let's see it's nice because every
time black wants to push F4 the pawn on
G4 is hanging by the way last move
before the time control move forward
right here
and again King G3 only move only move
Brandon is taking his time but don't
think about it don't even think about it
you gotta go King G3 to stay in the game
I mean I'm not worried I'm worried when
he has five seconds
Isaac so he might be afraid of King G3
Bishop G5 what's the follow-up because
of Bishop F4
and it's amazing and then well if you go
to H4 maybe he's well this is what he's
thinking about and he's down to 19
seconds
we know we know thanks to the engine
that he has to play King James critical
forties and we have the correct one here
wow
I mean guys I picked Jacobson as the
winner just want to say so and but he
won't be able to do that what a
sequence defensive it's up to Andrew to
make his four years move yes uh
but he has two minutes so he's good he's
good to go
do you take that pawn on E5 I do
I play Rook takes E5 uh a question for
you
um Christian did the engine think G4 was
was the best uh because I did like Rook
takes E5 and in case of
of
um no Rook takes C5 I would go A6 yeah
it doesn't change much
keeping these ponds on the board though
right well at some point you have to go
G4 right okay
it's it's not a big deal yeah Rook B5
Rook B7 and I still go A7
not a big deal takes takes King G3 on
the board and give us the engine eval
uh
zero zero yes yes close close to it zero
zeros well may not be it a playoff after
all uh Kate I mean it was close very
very close
as we're
as we're uh uh looking at Arthur's game
and I mean it's time to go maybe to the
junior girls section because yeah still
Zoe tank there
we have a guest in studio with Christian
over to you speaking of the junior girls
uh Carissa first of all congratulations
for a final round Victory important one
you played against a good friend of
yours and it was a complete back and
forth game how did you approach this one
um
I felt you know
this point
um tournaments not so great but I really
want to finish on like a good note so I
took the game pretty seriously
um
I think I definitely messed up a bit in
the opening there and I got very
frustrated after I allowed like this
queen C7 move otherwise I felt that
I think you were talking about uh
this moments when you allow the queen to
C7 and whereas I felt that maybe I
should have just played F4 instead and
then these sorts of structures which is
like kind of like a French Carl that
kind of thing is the types of my jam
yeah yeah
um but okay so I allow this can I play
with Queen G3 F4 and things kind of got
dicey on the queen side but I never felt
that there was like a very clear
knockout blow for her oh they certainly
did at this point she had this move
Bishop to E4 yes I did see that on the
engine you were planning to play a five
right I was going for F5 and I thought
like the complications and her time
trouble would be in the United States
crazy move B3 oh
if you take take on D2 and we didn't see
that one yeah touch the bullet on this
one I did I did got lucky
um but yeah after Bishop F5 I thought I
was doing okay but things are obviously
still complicated yes yes you are you
are definitely doing okay here
and I think this nice finish with
rooftex G7 yeah a difficult tournament
for you as you mentioned you came into
this tournament as one of the big favor
is to win it how would you assess it
what do you see as uh things that you
need to improve after this one tell us a
bit about that
um I haven't really had an opportunity
to look over my games a lot in depth
just because such a fast-paced
tournament but I think generally
speaking probably
some stuff my openings
um gave my opponents some chances
and
maybe I'm just like a little bit Rusty
with calculation and stuff I was missing
some important moves in like my critical
games
um
so I'll definitely have to take a look
at those if I have another tournament
coming up actually talk to us about that
what's next for you I know you have a
very busy academic career as well you go
to Stanford that's very very difficult
combine both that and just how do you
approach that what's next for you yeah
yeah so I'm playing in the Women's World
Cup in Baku so I'm flying out in two
days
and hopefully it'll be fun after I get
knocked out from that
I'll have a break from chess for a while
and then there's the Women's World team
in early September you want to be
playing what about the year championship
do we have
do we have you don't know yet I'm not
sure yet we'll see got it we'll see how
my tournaments go got it yeah well
Carissa congratulations on the last
round Victory and good luck at the World
Cup thank you our congratulations as
well a nice way to finish the tournament
yeah
congratulations on a nice and kind of a
nice touch for the tournament uh you're
exiting kind of the junior girls section
right this was your last year playing
the championship but you've won it three
times you won the US Women's
championships so what like how do you
feel about your kind of Junior career
when you are now entering the the
women's one
um yeah I mean it's a little bittersweet
as growing up usually is
um
but
not the best end to my Junior's career
but of course there's still going to be
a lot of tournaments to play and um
I'm excited for you know U.S women's and
all that coming up too
I hope it's not too bittersweet because
still you are a great American talent
very accomplished so you know one
tournament bathroom it happens but there
are a lot of them ahead thank you a lot
of bad tournaments ahead no
sir
[Laughter]
[Music]
um just looking at the remaining games
uh Kelsey rose that looks like uh it's
headed towards a draw a very even
sterile I would even go as far as to say
Rook ending
um very important game irismo against
Zoe tank Zoe uh fighting for the second
place in the u.sg I'd like Zoe's
position I don't like necessarily her
Bishop on B8 but I like this idea of
targeting this H4 Pawn with Bishop I
like Black's night
a Thor a god of thunder on the D5 Square
so I like her position and uh
I I like uh I like the extra Pawn I've
liked the extra pump for black for quite
a number of moves already but I wonder I
know uh Gracie's trading ponds right so
we are targeting Pawn on E6 but
Christian we have another guest
Josiah difficult tournament for you but
uh with a nice touch to finish it uh
good victory with the white pieces sum
up your experience here at the Junior
yeah I mean getting the wild card and
this is my last event as well I really
wanted to uh to do well but I just I
feel like I never really got on the
right foot and especially after the rest
day I just I lost three in a row and I
feel like uh maybe I just relax a bit
too much after the rest day and I just
kind of lost my focus
um but I mean overall I'm you know happy
to be here and obviously ending with a
win is pretty good going into my next
important tournament World Cup so I'm
pretty happy to finish off on a good
note so we're actually going with
Carissa as well and some other players
from the United States the World Cup
what are your Ambitions for that event
it's a big one
um well obviously every game I play I'll
be the the underdog and so you know I'm
just trying to go there and play good
chess honestly like going into every
event uh
moving forward I just want to play good
chess and especially after this
tournament like I really did not so
um you know I have Ambitions but at the
same time I just want to take it a game
at a time and see where that leads me
absolutely and I see you're sporting a
very nice jacket today that's uh the
Mizu chess jacket you should have
sported that a few more rounds maybe you
would have gotten some more victories
the two games that I won I was wearing
this jacket and actually
um at the Continental where I qualify
for the World Cup I wore this jacket
every single day there you go guys any
questions for uh lucky jacket yeah so
why are you not wearing the jacket
well actually I wore the jacket every
single game I played after continental
and I was like
undefeated for like 20 games wow and
then I lost the game it was actually
against Brandon at National open I was
like okay I'll retire the jacket for now
maybe I should have brought it back
oh I have a question
um not Brandon but uh Josiah we played
Duchess during the during the rest day
the 15 you know Club anniversary and I
was extremely surprised you are such a
strong Duchess player how long you've
been playing
that was actually only my only like my
third duck chess game like ever so I
don't know maybe I just had some
intuition for duck chess certainly
didn't carry over it too much into the
real games
A Gifted duck Chester definitely there
is a talent there absolutely
well congratulations on finishing this
tournament strongly and good luck at the
World Cup Championship
good luck uh for The Knockout those are
great tournaments uh two games going on
in the seniors we haven't really paid
that much attention to some time ago uh
Douglas had won a pawn or rather Patrick
had sacrificed upon and I look at this
position I think to myself boy I have
been frustrated so many times as a
French defense player with a light
squared Bishop like I'm dreaming if I
could just illegally you know take my D5
Pawn off the board I would play the move
D5 D4 and instantly have my Bishop on
this great diagonal the problem is the
blockade on the extra Pawn
really neutralizes the effect of the
extra Pond and I'm thinking that uh well
Patrick's got a blockade and he
shouldn't be risking anything in this
current position
and uh back over to you uh Christian as
we have another guest in studio Mishra
uh a draw for you but this was an
absolutely Wild game you had no idea
what's going to happen in the other
games before the round started how did
you approach today's game well today's
game I just wanted to have a fight okay
just play normal game whatever happens
will happen if I lose okay fine if I win
great just just play a normal game and
he came up with some blazing heart
preparation it felt like out of the
opening this F4 followed by this F5 in
fact I think this is novelty and he
played a game previously with castle
castle castle Knight D5 I remember
that's right that's right so you were
aware of this you prepared this as well
tell us a bit about this position what
was your preparation looking like yeah
this is a five move I didn't exactly
know the main idea is the is the fight
over the T5 Square
and here I basically had two candles
night before nt5 yes because the issue
is if you play a move like B5 which is
quite dramatic
the issue is at some point like maybe
okay even here engine says why like why
it is close to equal but I was worried
about let's say what I can just go
Knight D5 95 first okay and now like if
I play Knight takes D5 he takes D5 it's
the structure didn't look too good for
me but maybe I can go Knight ba D7 F6
maybe somehow I can make this work but I
was worried about the structure like if
like night before fails division before
correct yes and I have the stock India
has the sort of bind the another idea I
had was like D5 here this also look kind
of decent but the issue was like say one
idea of this is like e takes D5 now if
Dai takes D5 you go like even Bishop E4
like this oh sorry this should be four
friendly it doesn't work but some
structure like even if cast yeah Castle
yeah probably Castle Knight C3 bc3 yeah
the structure where white gets the
bishop 184 is actually quite unpleasant
because like visual CA cannot get out in
B5 counter play yeah yes so you chose
this move right to B4 and transition
into this yeah I think H3 is an accurate
like very it's very inaccurate very bad
because the issue is you I think you
basically have to go G5 here
yes and the reason why I played Bishop
D7 and not B5 is like okay generally in
the structure you go B5 Bishop B7 but I
was I was thinking that maybe in some
variations I can go long Castle so I
thought maybe I should just keep the
Palm Beach Seven keep it safe like that
yes here my idea was like say H6 G5
Bishop takes G5 I don't think engine
thinks this is a great idea but my idea
is Knight G4 Knight G4 yes yes very
interesting and now okay Bishop takes E7
Queen takes E7 somewhere I can even just
give up to G7 pawn and go long castle
for example like Queen G3 I go Knight
like Queen H4 it can also exist but like
Queen G3 I can go Knight F6 Queen G7
long Castle I go Rook G8 Bishop C6 D5
and I think we were you guys were
looking uh Yasser and kashka were
looking at this type of positions and he
played the movie H3 and yeah I think
this bishop Bishop this A4 move is
actually quite nice like it has to play
yeah right if he doesn't find it I think
he's like just like basically lost on
the spot right and this was the big
moment right here when you decide to
take on G4
um perhaps not the best best way but
then he played this move F6
yeah so
we saw you watching the clock uh a
little bit in a panic mode were you
panicking at all or
at first I wanted to play Bishop B5 I
felt like this has like resides yes but
the variation is actually quite great so
C4 Bishop takes C4 yes the first thing I
I saw that was that rukichi King D7 Rook
takes d8
Bishop takes d8 now let's say queen
takes
Queen takes E4
Rook takes C4 F takes G7 and now Rook
takes G4 and blackwoods correct so I saw
this variation I thought like okay maybe
black is winning here but then I
realized that actually here I think it's
actually not currently Rook takes d8
because black and play King takes DNA
and he's still like
probably still winning actually but the
issue with this is actually rookie King
design correct he forces The Rook to C5
then he takes on d8 on the fifth right
the ship takes dnf takes G7 enough on
Queens no more taking on C4 no more Rook
G4 yeah this was a nice variation and
you started calculating that you spotted
they depleted I thought we should feed
and now this is actually just this
should be winning for black but the
issue is apparently the engine doesn't
like the screen F6 move but I was
considering keeping the queen on C7 but
I was worried that in some cases black
white can go like rookie seven Bishop H6
like apparently it works out tactically
but during the game it's even very scary
to keep the queen away from the King
once you play Queen G6 I'll be Mario uh
you must know that this is probably
going to end in a draw yeah you can't I
did this variation I thought okay this
was working for me but I miscalculated
like in the end this queen D7 oh so all
the way towards you yeah because this is
all forced because if Queen G6 Works
actually let's go back to that position
for
but like Queen Queen E4 position
so here I had a choice whether I go
Bishop takes B3 Bishop D7 Queen G6 or
basically any of these
all these three moves the first thing I
wanted to play was like Bishop takes b3c
takes B3 Queen G6 yes but I was worried
that okay Queen takes G6 F takes G6 like
this end game is apply a pawn but just
looking it's even very very difficult to
convert probably yes I thought it would
probably be a draw so
and another like that I didn't want to
give up my Bishop I thought if I can get
the same end game with Queen without
trading on B3 I should just be
completely winning yeah I had another
idea instead of Bishop D7 I was
considering B5 also
it looks ridiculous with the idea of
like Rook C4
yes but I was worried that somewhere
like
maybe like say G5 for example
this is not like totally accurate but
Queen G
H but here neither one he has B4 okay so
maybe
four but maybe even B5 Knight A1
directly but Knight A1 yeah Knight A1
now the issue is if I go Rook C4 I just
kind of lose a piece
is somehow good for black but this is
pushing pawns yeah I mean you cannot
going from B7 to B4 I didn't see how it
kind of helped me as such it doesn't
make a lot of practical sense yeah so
then you decided did you look at the
other games at this point no no I had
like 14 minutes I spent eight minutes I
thought this was working because the
issue is if I go Bishop D7 like Bishop
D7 also looked like a normal move but I
was worried that white gets counter
played by the means of 95 yes and now it
comes to C6 and now okay game is already
I'm up by a part I have a bishop pair
but it's still very it's here like white
is definitely in the game oh yeah
absolutely things get complicated in
this one and you decide to go with Queen
G6 I saw some nice variations here like
okay Queen x86 is definitely the move
you have to play but for example like
Queen A2 I could if someone doesn't see
this this queen D7 drove you could think
that King E1 maybe this somehow holds
the queen E4 Rook H3 but instead of
Queen E4 I think Rook C3 is just resigns
oh very nice okay it's not very relevant
but okay v92 doesn't work well I'll be
one of you it seems like everything is
looking like it's working out in your
favor in this one our tour not looking
good for him in this one uh what about
the Brandon this was yeah big one right
you must have felt those last few moves
when he had only moves your heart must
be racing I wasn't really watching this
game walking outside but yeah this looks
this still looks very very possible to
mess this up double-edged yeah very
double-edged like three King G2 okay
just first thing is okay F4 Rook takes
E7 you shouldn't blunder well you can
yeah you can at least go locator okay
yeah it should be a draw don't do F4
yeah yeah don't do F4 everything
um yeah well I'll be reminding you we'll
let you go we'll let you go watch the
final moments of those two last games
and uh well we're not gonna congratulate
you for anything right now maybe we'll
talk yeah this isn't how I would want to
win the tournament yeah it's this game I
should have found some way to make this
work
guys any questions maybe just a very
quick question I'll be Manu I mean very
interesting game
um in the last moment you decided to go
King f8 to just repeat but you were
looking at this move King F6 uh which is
very dangerous and we weren't sure if
you are going to play it how what were
you thinking in that moment and why did
you not play that yeah instead of King
F6 was actually what I was playing to
play at the start but like when I was
calculating this variation from Queen G6
but the issue here is Queen D7
and now actually originally I was
considering Queen H7 but then I realized
Queen D6 is made in one so this guy this
queen takes D6 is very big issue so
Queen G2 check is probably the only
move King D1
Rook takes D2
Bishop takes D2 Queen takes D5 I think I
might have seen this far from beginning
but I kind of missed that White House
like in the worst case scenario where I
can go Queen d8 check
King G6
check on G5
King H7 Queen H4 check and just
perpetual
and also other than this maybe white has
some other moves in my king is still a
bit weak so I just I thought okay if
white has minimum controls make a draw
and go back before something bad happens
yeah I was thinking maybe if it was
around three you would go for some risk
we can get six but now it's maybe not
the time to take risk as this may be an
important draw for the championship so
congratulations really nice game thank
you absolutely as uh we're gonna just
take a quick break as we keep an eye on
the game between Arthur and Kirk as well
as Brandon and Andrew will Andrew join
Mishra in the playoff we'll see you on
the other side of the break to answer
that question
[Music]
hi everyone we are here at the 15th
anniversary of Saint Louis chess club in
Central West End it's also International
Chess Day there is a lot of fun going on
behind us let's go check that out
[Music]
foreign
tastic day so we have a beautiful
weather and then there are so many
players here even from the like U.S
juniors seniors girls we are playing
Dark Chess By the way you can see my
face paint and it's so fun to see all
the players yesterday is playing Dark
chess even Josiah steering Carissa
everybody here so it's really fun to to
be just experiencing chess we have a lot
of kids here we have a lot of adults a
lot of Club players so I think
everybody's really enjoying the chess
atmosphere celebrating 15th anniversary
of the club and
um I mean it's just really fun I think
everybody who started this formation of
the St Louis chess club it has truly
been a great advancement to the game of
chess especially in this country and I'm
just so excited to be here and play all
like just chess with other people who do
as well I'm just so happy and so elated
wow what does a club mean to me well it
changed my life if I wasn't doing the
commentatory I'd be watching
so now I've got the best job in the
world I've got a front row seat
I get to mingle with the chess players
and I get to watch the greatest games in
the world unfold in front of me and it's
been a life-changing and the most
rewarding experience my chess crew
I'm 15 years older and I'm still here
that's pretty good
now I see what it is I realize we have
such an incredible staff like you guys
that it's just remarkably successful
there's no question it's the best club
in the country if not the world
it was a wonderful day full of fun
celebration and ice cream I Just Want to
Thank You Saint Louis chess club for an
amazing 15 years happy International
Chess Day
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
hello I'm women's current Master William
Tucker jonova I will be doing social
media for the US Juniors and seniors
chess championships follow us in our
social media and get more exciting
behind the scenes action
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomes chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
hello I'm women's Grandmaster William
Tucker jonoa I'm doing social media for
the US Juniors and seniors championships
here in San Luis follow us for more
exciting behind the scenes content
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varusha nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 2 250 000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write Jess thanks to Club co-founder
Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield anyone can
learn how to understand chess notation
in no time we view chess as a valuable
educational tool learn more about our
Scholastic programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
foreign
and welcome back to our national
championship we have results yes results
round nine for the U.S junior girls
Championship Yip won against Wu and
mangalam lost against Lee
and in the seniors
we have a number of draws here Tylenol
of true with loogie shovel of Drew with
Katya and akopian Druid gorevich and
finally all eyes on the Juniors as uh
Drew with Mishra very important draw
with Mishra and Steelman won against the
end and Jake uh Brandon Jacobson and
Andrew Han are in play can Andrew win
the game and force potentially force a
playoff should he do so the engines
don't seem to say that the advantage is
significantly enough but I tell you when
you sit there and look at this position
um
as black you sure feel like you've got
chances at least uh of winning the
problem that Andrew is currently facing
is the very desirable move is to play F4
followed by Rook a to check and force
the king and then you can push the pawns
up the board the problem is white
actually has a threat at the moment
similarly to what black had before
exactly yeah you can give up the uh the
rook and Fork the bishop pardon me Fork
the rook and king with the bishop so you
can't play F4
if you give a check then I'm not going
to allow you you to play F4 by
retreating my king rather I'm going to
pull my king on G3 if this is the
problem that you can't get F4 and G4 uh
going uh and that's why we think the
game is a draw but Arthur is suffering
terribly uh it looks like he's
completely busted Christian oh yes in
this one oh yes there is no way out of
out of this one the problem is your king
is completely stuck
there is no way you can release it and
then create some sort of counter chances
the queen has to stay on the first rank
to defend against Queen to H1 and we're
talking about the other game right now
this is the Jacobson versus Andrew Hong
we're talking about the uh Goa game
versus razerian
and this is what I'm talking about that
Bishop B3 is doing an absolutely
tremendous job of stopping any solar
counter play now you can go Queen B4 and
exchange the Queens it's not going to
help you and black picked a lot of white
pawns yes on the way giving checks yes
yes so black I believe is a couple of
phones up right now but it's not even
about that it's about the fact that that
bishopon B3 stops any sort of counter
play while my Pawns in any end game are
going to go down the board very quickly
well now that you mentioned it uh if
white doesn't play Queen B4 check on
blacks agenda is quite possibly Queen D3
check and queen D1 that's right so I'm
just forcing the trade of Queens
regardless should I want and that's why
we think these three pawns are going to
just go
blasting up the board very you can give
a check on e4 but then I just simply go
D5 you cannot touch the E5 Pawn
is just the weakness of the king coupled
with the fact that those spawns are just
simply going down the board exactly this
feels like uh
it's over yeah very difficult game
because uh after ago if he would be able
to manage to make a draw here he's in
the playoffs
it's so frustrating for him right now
and you know he he knows the result he
knows the position he came into this
rounding I mean with the white pieces
and the position he got out of the
opening was so Superior I mean he could
only be uh frustrated as
it's a tough situation yeah he had it
you know he had at least a tie breaks
right in the back but unfortunately for
him look he took the chances but maybe
didn't take those chances at the right
moment I mean kudos to Kurt right you
know he is not in position to play for
any of the top spots if I'm not mistaken
he's not making the podium right but
he's been hanging on he's impactful uh
for the standings that's for darn sure
oh yes
um and then the girls uh fight for the
second place
Arthur just made a move sorry it was I
kind of waiting around for Arthur to
make a move he did play King A1 King A1
yes but this is a very good position and
Kirk has 32 minutes you probably think I
think we should go to the other one I
think they are repeating
Andrew Andrew Hong versus Brandon um I
believe they have let's take this
repetition quite a few times already
so the last few moves after A6 were
route to A3
King G2 Rook a 2 King G3 and in fact
King G3 was the third time repetition
um
I believe
maybe not no with the Rook on A2 so
right now black can claim a three-time
repetition with root 283 right and if he
plays Rook A3 then white can claim a
three-time repetition with King G2
we're very close from potentially
seeing this one and crucial game and
I don't know if I was in black shoes I'd
still be tempted to try
to play
um
with the move Bishop to G5 by the way
I'm curious sorry too no no no if Andrew
makes through K3 but he does not claim
draw can Brandon just going to draw
without suggesting a move because it's a
three
no I think he has to say I'm going to
play this move because he can play King
F2 and that would be
because yes I know j3 is a threefold
repetition and if Andrew doesn't claim
it maybe Brandon can claim it with King
G2 yes yes
the final time and and the final third
time repetition now as you can see
Brandon also frustrating for these two
players right neither one of them needed
to draw they needed to win look they're
good friends but I mean this is business
and this is exactly what's happening
right now they they're fighting it off
to a draw and fortunately that's not
going to give either of them that
Championship or that tie breaks for the
championship
yeah
both have been looking away from one
another there that was good that was
that was special I wanted to go to the
lady uh girls pardon me
um as uh Zoe Tang
um second place yes she is and
I really like her position when we left
it night to B6 huh
wow okay Knight to B6 so she's saying
give me the pawn and I want to undermine
this night on B5 at the same time by the
way she's defending her Pawn on C4 and
looks very favorable for black
Knight
rerouting the Knight to attack on C4
okay so just a second let me play
devil's advocate here take a pawn you
can't really take this guy because F3
would be hanging right in that case
Knight takes season four and I love my
knight I mean I'm sorry I just because
they're not gonna try that one it might
not although wait sorry excuse me no
Queen A2 I was hitting the night I was
hitting the bishop but I was walking
into Rook C2 sorry
just uh
yeah Knight to D5 it feels very very
good are there some tricks like Bishop
takes eight six
well it's it's a pawn
it's not uh necessarily
upon I'm not going to take I'm not going
to allow Queen and G6 check
somehow it's a little frustrating you
would want more wouldn't you
because Queen G6 can be a threat
with E6 being attacked G7 being attacked
I do have this as a defense but the
thing is uh how do I how do I put this
guy to work I mean I've got this extra
Pawn on G3
it would be nice to utilize it wouldn't
it
yeah not so easy not that easy I guess
at just taking a pawn
looks a little funny but you take a pawn
I take upon and we just both mutually
kind of maul one another queen Jesus
Queen G7
for the queen
a little bit passive agreed
Queen takes G3 yeah
um
I actually thought maybe with the King
but it works too yeah King takes C3
funny how I didn't want to put my just
you know
and this again Zoe has taken Let me
refresh my board Because by the way the
Rue Yang Yan also
um
a big fight for uh is
in the fight for a second she did play
Queen takes A4 we're anticipating Knight
takes E4
and this is where we got into that
position with the queen dropping in on
G6
that's strange I would I would have
hoped that there was more to it than
this
for Zoe because
this isn't not convincing uh not a
convincing win I agree with you for Zoe
why this one United Knight takes C4 on
the board
exactly uh let's take a look at the game
between Gracie and Roo Yang Yan uh and
again uh rouyang
she's fighting for second and she's been
a pawn up uh for much of the game she's
got the minor piece uh the bishop versus
the Knight pawns on both flanks usually
favorable for the bishop over the night
yeah she's certainly playing for win but
it may not be that easy still because
white has this very active night on F4
The Rook kind of targeting then Pawn on
E6 so I don't give you give you time to
recapture on A3 exactly taking on A3
I'll take but in the meanwhile uh I
don't know is this Knight going to
really be that stable so I'm thinking
that from Black's perspective she might
be looking to play a move like rookie 4
and Bishop E3 by the way I do believe
it's white Unturned
and also it's important to know that
black has the good Bishop right that
yeah A1 square is dark so there if we
play some kind of G3 to change that
um sacrifice a night then we still I
mean lose that end game because
um yeah Bishop controls the promotion is
dark Square exactly
yeah what is happening oh we have an end
game so that should be easy to evaluate
whether this was the working part ending
uh strange every time I I think to
myself well you know game will be a draw
you know it's easy something happens and
it's like what
something happens yeah so Rose bone
thoroughly exchanged the Rooks because
this is a draw
we captured upon we play King A5 back
allow the white to capture the pawn
but hold the
by the way guys Andrew down to his last
four minutes I don't know if it matters
we've seen this movie before
they they we counted down a few times to
five and seven seconds I remember that
you can't trick us this one is going to
be a draw
five yeah very proficient at this King
opponent games again players cannot
agree on draw so we're gonna see it all
the way to the stalemate
but we can definitely call this a draw
or you can go B4 King B5 King B2 you
know
or you can make a three four repetition
right
are we going to see
Kelsey called The Arbiter one of them
called The Arbiter or
no no before not yet no calling the
Arbiter either
I think perhaps
let's do it one more time just to make
sure and I think now she can already
claim and I think right now and she's
also looking at the score sheet making
sure that King C5
I'm not sure it's a threefold repetition
but why are the player so reluctant to
accept the punishment of two minutes
yeah I just stop the clock and say hey
I'm gonna do this and my opponent gets
an extra two minutes enjoy yourself
again exactly be happy uh Arthur it
looks like it's time to give it a rest
the last move E5 E4 looks very very
convincing for black uh in uh against
Kirk that's right yes
and we do know Arthur's dreams are dying
hard here Bishop to C1
he's not giving up yet nope
not giving up yet
um Bishop to C1 covering that first Rank
and now at least
freeing up the queen to
try for something Queen A5 I mean so
let's play like Queen C2 right making
sure that white cannot try anything oh
you're being mean I know
let's say expression those that never
admit defeat are seldom ever defeated
that's yes queen queen
yeah that that should be enough
and Andrew seems to be reciting
for repetition Rook to A3 was played in
that one they're looking at each other I
don't know if they call the Arbiter yet
but
and Mishra is cheering this result
that's for sure yes there we go yeah
with the move King G2 is a three-fold
repetition
yeah
that is a correct claim the Arbiter will
soon um Andrew is smiling he did
everything he could he tried everything
he could he they they truly battle the
doll out that was a nice try that Rook
takes G4 check
none of them are happy
but they're so disappointed sometimes
disappointed that it was not what we
would call a hearty hand class
barely touching right yeah
none of them happy because if one of
them won they there would be a playoff
for the first place it was just a good
game look I mean it was a great game it
was a good game
they tried but it just wasn't through
the magic of Television we're about to
present to you the worst handshake ever
let's see if it goes viral
there it is a touching a touching of the
fingertips
do you remember WC Fields I think it was
the bank robber I'm not sure where WC
Fields rescues the day and saves the
bank from a robbery they're looking at
this bishop before yeah that was the
last way to try for anything
right this was the mate that uh he's
showing him some sort of like just
getting H5
Checkmate pattern
because he can give up this bishop
exactly and then there's Rook f8 check
promoting to a queen
but why did that work
because there was King G7
but then Ruby
King H7
oh and I don't have no I do have Rook h8
Bishop takes 18.
and we cannot uh Crown a champion until
Kirk
wins the game because uh if Arthur could
achieve any kind of a result a draw
yeah you really know where that Queen is
going but Kirk did play the Rooks the
Queen City move yes not allowing
anything for white to do now he
retreated his Bishop he's ready to run
with the pawns I think Queen C4 is the
uh it just shuts
I'll just go d3d2 or E3 E2
uh e
3 do have a check now it's a
yeah yeah Queen C4 is you know let's
exchange the Queens let's go that's what
I mean that's what I would do and just
put the uh put it to rest you don't have
to calculate anything in that one um
yeah
look there's a lot of ways to win this
position no for sure it has 28 minutes
so he's gonna really calculate to make
sure he's not gonna mess up in the last
last part of the game but there are a
lot of ways to win
and we have another game that is over
here
one or at least she's probably going to
get second place yeah she won again a
crazy Persona I mean it's important how
Zoe tank is gonna do
um
right
because I believe they are
is there a tie between them
if Zoe yes right now it's it's a tie but
Zoe I don't think she's winning that one
it's all about that Arthur versus oh by
the way can we look at the Zoe skin
because Bishop takes H6 is on the board
and once again just one and Bishop takes
H6 so they're they're following our
analysis and we didn't find
a win for Zoe after Bishop H6
it's a very nice resource
sorry you mean a win for Iris
no we thought that Zoe was playing for
the win oh no no no no no no I think Zoe
is playing for a loss right now
if she's playing for anything no no page
six I think she's in trouble really yes
it was in Queen D7 I was trying to take
a pawn sorry oh you were not trying to
take a pond yeah let's try to take a
pawn queen takes B4 and I think you were
going Queen she's six and I was going
Queen E7 and then you were saying maybe
King takes G3 or or queen takes G3 and
then it was like one two three
uh three versus four I'm an extra Pawn
Yeah Yeah and uh it was just like one of
those things where well okay the night
on D5 still makes this very powerful
impression but I can try to be rerouting
The Rook maybe Rook E1 Rook E4 Rook G4
one rookie 4 Rook G4 or maybe maybe yeah
maybe faster some something simpler than
Rook G1 and King H I don't know King
each week by the way Queen
so though he's not capturing that Bishop
she is just like I want to retreat with
my queen making sure
Bishop takes H6 not Queen takes sorry
let me just refresh my board apologies
for that Queen E8
what is that move
so now after
now she's one Pawn down but whenever I
capture the pawn on G3 I'm gonna be two
pawns up exactly oh maybe I can just go
Bishop G5 yeah and just that's an extra
I have everything protected I have to
say you might get in trouble if you take
on B4 with the Knight first of all I can
take on B7 right but no no no no I was
never uh on that direction I mean now we
can see how the bishop on G5 is
fantastic compared to its counterpart on
ba well we used to have a Pawn on H6
that was a good Bond I was uh keeping
the G5 Square uh I I'm gonna say Iris
has turned this around I I thought that
Zoe was the one who was pushing things
earlier now I'm no longer
yeah no I mean I I like Iris
after King takes G the bishop G5 King
takes G3 by the way if we go back to
Arthur go and Kirk gazarian's game there
was Queen C4 on the board they traded
the Queens right and now the black plots
are running very very fast they
certainly are
B4 by author but uh
he three King D5 King E4 and E D3 here
we go
let's do it let's do it and he's done it
push him baby
yeah King is coming by the way there is
a also even now that we've shut off the
bishop right there's even H6 and G5 as
well I think that's what he's going for
H6 G5 yeah there's no way to get to my
okay King D5 King E4 D3 right
because the good thing is the white
pawns on the queen side a three and
before they can never like yeah they can
never be pushed to cause any trouble
exactly exactly A4
I mean once you've gone B5 you'll have
to play B6 and the bishop will just drop
back so yeah
King to E4 and if you go A5 well The
Bishop's perfectly defending
um Arthur and roses and by the way I
can't even go King D3 next I don't even
have to go D3
wow King to D3 okay just so that's very
nice you cannot even sacrifice the
bishop exactly and the next turn is uh
E2 King D3 is very nice move
very nice film I think that just
finished I have a feeling we will see
that yep yep here we go
candy three you can go B6 but as you
mentioned yeah sir pitch Basics right
stops everything in its tracks
wow Last Hope
Last Chance Saloon nope Bishop A6 shuts
it down and E2 and I think we're about
to Crown a champion
that's it there will be no playoffs
tomorrow because we will have champions
for all tournaments today
and uh for Mishra I mean it will be his
first crack at the national championship
the world's youngest Grandmaster and
likely not his last one and likely not
his last one
not his last one
B7 B7 maybe you're not going to take
that part
well that lasted a whole three seconds
didn't it I think less than that yeah
wow that's it that's the championship he
played such a wonderful wonderful
Championship
wow here heartbreaking loss but Juan
abhimanyu Mishra right now here's the
2023 U.S junior Champion twelve thousand
dollars happier
and he's also having a nice ticket to
the U.S chess championships well as a
ten thousand dollar scholarship to the
University of College of his choice
that's not our congratulations to Mishra
uh also unblemished he did not lose a
single game I mean this youngest
Grandmaster ever really playing
fantastically in this tournament and is
that Andrew and Brandon still
they have really still analyzed me it's
been like 20 minutes guys exactly ever
since the Hardy hand clasp they're still
analyzing wow
they really want to understand this end
game if it is a draw or if maybe Andrew
had any chances exactly
I had some seniors uh tournaments are
still in progress as we have
Joel Ben Igor novikov and Joel Benjamin
as well as Patrick Wolff and Douglas
root they're still playing and we have a
guest in studio Christian royang another
big victory for you in the last round
it's always nice to finish with a bang
but also I think with this one you have
great chances to finish second how would
you assess yours I don't care I'm just
like with the way my tournament started
I'm just glad I did this
absolutely absolutely and you will also
probably be getting an invitation based
on your rating to the US Women's Chess
Championship how are you seeing that
play out for you um
honestly I will be more worried about
like school like I've been missing like
two weeks of school and taking like a
lot of eight piece next year too so are
you ready to go to college soon or like
what's up yeah I'll be a junior next
year Junior next year so still have a
few years left before College a year or
so young uh that was just uh impressive
Stellar play in the last few rounds I
have to say you were just like
dominating your opponents uh despite the
fact that you started slow you finish
strong and that's what matters
congratulations guys any questions
absolutely uh just to say it was a great
event I enjoyed watching your games and
congratulations you're young for a nice
finish second place in the tournament it
was a big field you you're not exactly a
favorite when Carissa and Alice is in
the field but you must be pleased with
your performance
yeah congratulations very nicely exactly
uh Patrick Wolfe and uh Douglas root
they have been playing a position which
I am kind of confused
there's nothing that that could possibly
do this night is on C2 and it's a
perfect blockade you you can't do
anything with this terrible Bishop on uh
the C6 Square as you just said
so can I try for some what about Knight
D3 Knight C5
uh Knight D3
are you
me any chances with you thank you
it's not there's no I was just wondering
if you were just giving me uh any
any chances if it's funny if I if you go
Knight C5 then I go Bishop takes C5 and
you go Queen takes A3 I go Bishop takes
D4 I get the two Bishops for a queen
protective never mind never mind never
mind
not sure at all so what about eager
novikov and Joe Benjamin how is that
game looking
but uh we'll pause for a moment because
we have the champion in studio we found
him
welcome back to the studio first of all
congratulations those results did go
your way and you are the 2023 Junior
chess champion how are you feeling right
now feels amazing you're going to have a
chance to play against all the greats of
the game Fabiano Wesley Hikaru feels it
it's it's an amazing feeling
how important is that ticket to the U.S
Championship because we were talking
about it it's so difficult to make it
based on the rating right now with the
US Championship you have to be around
2700 to even hope that you're going to
make it how important it is for you to
meet those
greats of the game it was very important
that was the main purpose of coming here
like this tournament is very strong in
itself but I came here to win this
tournament to play in that U.S
championship and you've said this at the
beginning there is no other place that
matters it's first place or nothing and
you prove that from the beginning to the
end through your fighting spirit
what would you say are things that
you're happy with after this event based
on your play and things that you could
improve in order to meet those grades in
good shape sure one thing I need to do
is start playing more openings for sure
like half of like two games like for
example against Brandon and Jason they
were just draws out of the opening so I
need to diversify my openings
and also I feel that some games like
randomly like for example my games
against Kirk or right my games against
my games against Kirk or Josiah like
these randomly I have these sort of off
days where I just play absolutely
terrible chess
but what is your main attribute that
you're happy with living this story
about there must be at least one I guess
it's just don't even in terrible
positions like in both of the games
against Kirk and Josiah I was playing
terribly I had dead lost positions and
even then I managed to hold them so I
guess it's my my ability to to defend
here and I guess yeah that's the that's
the thing that made all the difference
in the end I have compared to all the
other competitors I haven't lost a
single game resilience is absolutely key
especially when uh later in October when
you will be facing uh the players at the
USS championships Happy Money
congratulations just an inspiring
performance guys any questions for our
champion I will just Echo our
congratulations as well Mishra uh well
done well done Bravo yeah
congratulations very much I do have one
quick question and that is uh for the US
Championship that you qualified how are
you going to prepare are you going to
mostly study like openings that you're
going to play against your opponent or
do you want to maybe get more
tournaments so you are
um you know not Rusty when you are
entering that competition
yeah so now I have another couple
tournaments lined up like as of now
another five days I'll be coming back
here for summer chess classic right
against all like 2600 plus opposition
after that I'm going to play in Spain
either some Spanish leagues so yeah I
have a I have another couple tournaments
before
uh the US championship
and do everything breaks for him like
are you gonna take like few days off to
celebrate to to kind of recharge not do
chess or do you just non-stop yeah
probably I'll take some break after like
another two three days and then I'll go
back to preparing for the next event
well congratulations really fantastic
accomplishment thank you yeah well done
very well done as uh just looking at the
game between Igor and they're still
there they're still analyzing there's
nothing like happy money go join them
don't show them what they missed
nothing like a good postmortem I'm
really surprised because in the old days
the post-mortems were a very enjoyable
part of Chess today it's like the
players just run back to the to their
hotels to look at the chess engines and
3200 rated opponents and say you know
like what did I miss
as opposed to analyzing with one another
it's nice to see right but at many
tournaments like olympias always the
Arbiter they kick you out they kick you
out right yeah no talking nothing so
it's nice to see that these guys still
have space there to to analyze and here
we see uh Zoe tank against Iris Moe and
she did play that Iris did play that
variation with Bishop G5 but she did not
capture later the pawn on B7
that's a verrasi that's a surprise right
or what happened maybe why did she do
that
she snuck upon Bishop we left it after
the move Queen E8 Bishop G5 and we
thought okay now iris is beginning
to cook take this Pawn B5 B5 all right
so now in the Knight capture there's no
capturing on B7 and this is how how she
kind of ducked and dodged
that moment there but when you look at
the clock I already smoke five minutes
40 seconds Zoe 10 only two minutes 37
seconds
yeah the problem is this uh structure
I want to play D5 I really want to play
D5 I don't want to lose my Pawn on E5 so
I'm thinking I would love to play F4
followed by D5 and then you know if you
play B4 B4 I'll I'll take with the
Knight and I'm gonna have this
dominating position it feels like Iris
yeah there was this big question can we
capture Rook takes B5 is there any like
strong discover attack with the Knight
jumping somewhere I was afraid if
there's a there was a check on
um
on B2 so it only occurred to me later
that
Rook takes B8 Queen takes B8 you could
actually play Rook takes E5 I didn't see
it I only saw Rook takes b87 on the
board so Rook takes B5 Bishop A7 on the
board and this the clocks yeah players
don't have much time five minutes for
Iris two Factor almost three minutes for
Zoe
okay the things are perking up here just
a second uh you you mentioned his
discoveries so Knight takes D4 and a
rook will be hanging
and the thing is after you play Knight
D4 I have Rook B7 coming so that might
be a bit problematic for you
okay
so you mean I should just make a move
uh invite Knight takes D4 so that I can
play Rook B7
Knight H6 tricks
S6 could be an option
so something like this and Knight H6
check yeah that is game over Queen G6
yikes uh we've seen these tactics on the
G6 Square when we sacrifice a piece on
H6 we'll pause our uh we'll pause our
analysis as we have a spoiler Studio
Kirk you weren't playing for the
championship but you could affect the
standings and you did just that how are
you feeling right now with this last few
games performances
I mean
I don't know I mean this game was just a
complete mess but this is what I was
striving for before the game I just
wanted to play a very cute chaotic
stressful game I just think uh I mean my
opponent basically uh
didn't play so good under a lot of
stress which is understandable because
he was obviously fighting for first
place and doesn't want to lose with
white
a stressful game I don't think I've ever
heard that before you were running for a
stressful game that's very interesting
because for both sides of course but
especially for him because he was
playing with so much pressure on his
shoulders that's a very intriguing
strategy how did you come up to that
with that idea I mean I I think I've
been on the receiving end of that a
couple of times in my life but um that's
why I chose this uh dubious open
Sicilian line for black I didn't know
the lines so well but even if the
position goes bad it's very hard for
white to keep everything under control
in these types of games the evaluations
change a lot and it's a very complicated
position and another thing that you were
doing you were putting a lot of pressure
on your opponent's clock early on you're
playing fast even though you said that
you didn't know the opening but you were
still playing fast confident chess tell
us a bit about when you felt you're
starting to gain the advantage you're
starting to take over yeah so first of
all I played uh fast so I could put them
under more stress on the clock because
of course even though he knows he's much
better in that position it's very hard
to find the exact way for white to
improve his position and also it's not
pleasant when the opponent's worst they
keep making aggressive moves quickly I
thought I was better when he allowed
Bishop E2 I think he missed Bishop E2
yes yes that's what we thought as well
uh Bishop to E2 was a big turnover
turn around for this game maybe F5 this
was an interesting move did you consider
this move at all didn't even consider it
probably my opponent didn't either I
thought he was going to give the
exchange but not like that like Rook G1
maybe and then G5 something like that
yeah something like this or even G5 in
the first position one of those two
moves I I didn't think of F5 at all F5
is so counter-intuitive because you hang
the g-pawn and The Rook exactly yeah wow
yeah and I I mean it's not probably the
best move and it still remains
complicated uh but I thought it's an
interesting way to try to open up and
make space for his pawns to be pushed
right yeah c66 things of that nature
correct
big game big win for you congratulations
it's all important to perform well in
this type of stressful situation so
that's something that our viewers can
definitely take away from this one
congratulations and we'll see you
perhaps next year thank you
our congratulations as well Kirk
definitely a fighting game today in this
Championship round Great Stop love right
and also I believe Kirk is leaving soon
to Azerbaijan for the World Cup so this
could be a nice kind of warm-up for that
event it could kickoff right yes uh Zoe
and uh Iris uh hard at work and
it feels like one of those positions
that's stressful
and I can easily imagine three results
coming out of this uh game I don't know
who might win uh your your quick take on
this one
um
okay this is like a don't you feel three
results yeah I'm kind of surprised that
we were retreating with that Queen I do
want that Knight G4 but I'm worried
about another Pawn that may be lost
Bishop look at this bishop F6 mean H7
check on
iris's agenda here whoa whoa whoa whoa
this is a scary looking move very
frightening looking I think you have to
go Rook F7 isn't that the only way to
defend it sure feels like it uh
everything else anything anything that
allows Rook G7 would be terrible if I
take well that's an exchange second okay
Rook F7 that's that's happened wait I
can maybe capture The Rook now and play
Queen H7 that's right yes
very dangerous well just a second I mean
I get I get it you've got a threat but
wait wait wait wait wait wait okay let's
let's be greedy first
let's show why greed is not a good idea
by the way on the board
take on E3 so Bishop takes you three
nights if black is greedy I'm being
greedy right now
takes
King King
and now I have to go 97 and use this one
is looking bad right you get kind of
blasted away there and you don't get to
keep the extra Knight Rook F7 on the
board
so who's playing okay who takes F7 and
then Queen H7 we discussed that right
and now Queen G8 well a a curious move
for me is right here how about them
apples 94 is also very nice yeah because
black cannot recapture that pawn that
Bishop on F6 yeah
and by the way I believe this game was a
draw yeah so we have a game Igor navikov
against Joel Benjamin which means
there's only one last game remaining in
the U.S seniors Championship the Patrick
Wolfe Douglas root game that's ongoing
but this game with Zoe seems to be
happening is uh going to decide second
place
and it's the clocks are down both
players down both of us are less than
three minutes yes Queen H7
here we go we might be seeing some
simplifications guys
Queen to H7 Queen to G8 seems to be the
way to go right and then perhaps Queen
takes G8 and Bishop G5 which leads to
massive simplification oh but then it
means Bishop F6 was it was a bluff can
we just give king queen H5 check I
thought that was the idea okay and now
G6
G6 sorry
I thought we were going to go I don't
like no no I I sorry I don't like
letting that Bishop live there I'd like
to kick it back King f8
go away Queen
G8 on the board will we see Queen H5
all right if you want to win it you
gotta risk it so you you gotta risk it
to earn the biscuit that's right that's
right these uh University Expressions
you know
I missed I missed them uh Queen G8 this
is the current position
and again eight minutes two minutes
right but one question what are the
simplifications aren't you losing
something after Queen takes
Bishop G5 they take Bishop G5 so you
give me the pawn on E5 yeah you take E5
I take G3 and well like take it with the
bishop F4
it's too simplified
simple
four and King takes
G35 on the board okay virus is not
simplifying
foreign
do you like G6 or do you like king of
eight no I think king of Fate no no you
you guys are right definitely not G6
King this thing just allows for like
Queen
I guess G5 Queen G5 just keeping every
oh yeah keeping everything intact
and I'm wondering if after
after night G4 but if we give up that
Bishop
just retreating giving up that pawn
perhaps Knight G4 works also but I think
it's just too risky right now
I have to say that this uh with the Rook
was on B7 she went Bishop F6 I I I have
a feeling that white had something there
maybe the immediate Knight G4 because
now she's gone back with the bishop and
really she's traded she forcibly traded
a rook on B7 for Rook on f8 why did we
do that our Rook on B7 was really a
an aggressive Rook yes I was definitely
hopeful for more for white in this in
the previous position exactly
me too I thought that there was more
there for Iris than what she got she
kind of cashed her chips a little uh
early I would say on this one
but we aren't expecting Zoe to recapture
on E5 yep
she may also go for Queen F7
Queen F7 that makes sense too right
just to it's not like whites I would go
check and maybe Queen backed
so Queen F7 is actually a very decent
move
personally take the pawn
what if I think with night kind of
blocking the queen from an escape Queen
F7 CF7 on the board she liked your move
Kate
I don't know if I like it that much you
want to take it back uh what's what's
bumming you out are you like Queen G4
now Queen G4 maybe we can take on E3 and
then take on e4 whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
Knight takes E5
and if I take the bishop you're gonna
Checkmate me oh
what else are we the tactics
in my youth
called me
what did they call you yes
we are very curious what did they call
you please finish that sentence the
damask and Diamond
okay the Syrian sorcerer
I like that the serium sorcerer
is that a a pet did we see a repetition
that's going to be repetition well the
writing now no it wasn't signatures I
mean Zoe is already checking her score
sheet but
now when iris is going to retreat with
her Queen I believe Zoe is gonna write
down Queen F7 yeah as a third repetition
agreed
I'm telling you Arbiters really get
they're working yes climbs here yeah
they're working aren't they Queen F7
and it is a correct claim the game is a
draw
which means we have all games done in
the girls section
as a result of this result is clear
second we'll find that out shortly in
our standings and what do we have left
Christian just one game just one game in
the senior section that's the one
expecting this one to be a draw anytime
soon as well they're still fighting
about it doesn't seem like there's much
to be
fighting about it before I thought that
Knight can be very strong there's really
nothing to to play for whites to try for
Advantage well I am a pawn up the
question is
and the problem is that whenever you
land let's say a knight on F6 right
right I'm just gonna capture that
instantaneously and there's no follow-up
and I think that's the only entry Square
uh if you attack my opponent B5 I defend
it with the bishop on C6
so can I do so let's say King D4 right
King D4 just to stop right any potential
and now we can move maneuver our night
if we would like to F6 okay he's going
for it yeah right
um just moved the bishop Maybe
Bishop 8 Bishop C6
back and forth yeah yes yes
no I mean it feels like uh feels like a
complete and anytime
and the thing is they have been
playing this end game for a while like
it's
I think they've been playing it for
almost 20 moves 20 yes
like they've exchanged the Queens at
move 58 now they're at move 71 so
well I I want to say to the players an
enormous number of decisive games and
this the championship round I think is
this the first time that the seniors
Drew all of the games I believe so yeah
I mean uh all the games were drawn in
this
and uh for those of you who want to know
there's a lot more chess coming on right
any tournaments coming up chess nine
elix September 7 to 11. everything here
happening in Saint Louis then the U.S
and U.S women's Chess Championship in
October Saint Louis rapid and Blitz very
popular event and of course a single cup
in November for the for the grand chess
tour title uh who will be the new Grand
chess tour winner and the hundred
thousand dollar bonus for winning that
event
and of course you saw you heard Mishra
saying that he's returning to St Louis
shortly for the chess classic as well we
won't have the broadcast for that but on
the St Louis chess Channel we'll
certainly have some uh commentary I
think you will be doing the broadcast
yes sir aren't you yeah I'm hoping to
know a little bit uh you know
and was it yes
Arbiter said you're good enough guys you
you guys were so close on this one we
believe you really
believe you I like that I like that good
Arbiter good work good work to our
arbitrary team and just to refresh
everybody's memory how did we do what no
no no no no no it's the broadcast
junior girls we tried our best to
convince them I I mean I I'm glad I got
you to join my team I'm Tony you are
lying on in there I was the first one to
make that I was shocked shocked by this
Behavior what else happened what else
oh wow wow wow we're not worthy we're
not worthy say it with me and what about
our senior Champion okay this is the one
that counts come on this is this is the
most unpredictable one I took two first
in the second
what do you think good job good job
thank you very much
I was fishing for a compliment
for the next U.S seniors Championship
the wild card that's my reward final
standings let's go through them yeah
girls Championship honestly fantastic
performance second really great
tournament as well and then a two-way
tie for the third place and Zoe tank
and once more here is our champion yeah
beta Master Alice Lee 2023 U.S general
girls Champion congratulations
this means a lot to her yes we are very
happy for her I am elect please
absolutely
absolutely wow we have Emmanuel Mishra
the new U.S junior champion and then a
four-way tie actually for a second place
Brandon Jacobson Andrew Hong Balaji
dagupati and arturagua congratulations
to all of our competitors in that field
for a very very tough uh event indeed
and there is the youngest ever
Grandmaster abimano Mishra punching his
ticket for the U.S Championship he's
very excited about that event yeah the
2023 us Junior champion
playing with the Legends right there's
national championships so they're so
strong and then finally in the seniors
final standings here Medics at catchy
and the wild card in this tournament and
he won that event but what a great story
with 20 000 price money Second Place
Alex chabalov third place Vladimir
akopian no ties here it's a clear
serious it's a clear uh standing
absolutely and once again Malik said
yeah here we have in Grand Master
America the new 2023 U.S Senior champion
Christian we sum it all up for us say
these three national championships a lot
of fun always a pleasure uh to be here
in St Louis doing commentary but
especially for these three Championship
because it feels like we're seeing
Future Stars grow in front of our eyes
and of course the Legends is always a
pleasure to see them play chess here at
the St Louis chess club amazing chess
amazing fighting Spirit from all these
competitors and I have to say there's so
much resilience in all three
championships look even the last game
they played until those last few moments
they didn't make those draws easily I
have to say it's always a pleasure to
watch and commentate on these three
national championships and it's been a
pleasure to watch and commentate with
you as well Christian Kate it was really
a lot of fun thank you so much you're
going to join us again right I don't
know but thank you very much for the
opportunity here to send this chess club
guys it's amazing to do commentary with
you I know this tournaments as a player
but never as a commentator now you know
what it means to be on this side and to
our audience thank you so much for
joining us I hope we we've uh I hope
you've enjoyed our commentary and these
national championships they were really
really competitive we enjoyed calling
them thank you so much for participating
and until next time thank you and see
you again
foreign
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited